je vois pas d'inconvénients pour ma part
aux explications de vote
mais j'avais pas de main qui est pas
j'ai pas vous aviez donné la main
je peux vous donner la parole dans
l'article 4 et vous vous expliquerez sur
l'article 3 si vous le souhaitez
ça changera pas grand chose madame Cohen
merci madame la Présidente l'article 4
entérine un mouvement qui existait déjà
poussé par des expérimentations ou des
volontés locales de faire entrer des
opérateurs privés dans le dispositif
national de retour à l'emploi nous nous
y opposons sur le principe la
privatisation d'activité en lien avec
les droits sociaux et particulièrement
dangereuse cela revient à sortir du
service public certains de nos
concitoyens et nos concitoyens alors
même que la mission dévolue au réseau
France travail relève du service public
et du droit social sur les questions de
performance enfin éclater la gouvernance
de France travail entre des entités
différentes et potentiellement
concurrentes est une fausse bonne idée
comment se répartiront les dossiers
entre public et privés sur quelle base
seront rémunérés les agences privées
s'il s'agit d'une rémunération au
placement d'un travailleur on risque
fort de voir une polarisation des
dossiers les plus simples entre les
mains de et les dossiers les plus
compliqués laissés au public développer
les moyens publics monsieur le ministre
plutôt que de généraliser l'appel au
supplétifs de la protection sociale je
vous remercie si monsieur vanderenberg
oui merci madame la Présidente bon je
vais pas quand même m'exprimer sur
l'article 3 qui est voté simplement je
voudrais je vous laisse simplement
souligner
que l'accord qui a été intervenu entre
madame le rapport Tom sur le ministre me
paraissait et excellent parce que ça
rééquilibré effectivement l'article 3 je
crois que on l'a beaucoup entendu ce qui
me paraît essentiel pas seulement les
sanctions c'est l'accompagnement et
l'accompagnement pour l'avoir
effectivement beaucoup pratiqué
personnellement et pour avoir
effectivement présidé une mission locale
je sais au combien il est important mais
pour ça il en faut les moyens
et les compétences et d'ailleurs les
deux se tiennent on n'aura pas les
compétences dans les organismes
d'insertion si on en a pas les moyens
alors monsieur le ministre vous avez
évoqué effectivement une enveloppe de 2
milliards 3
je ne sais pas si elle sera suffisante
tous les cas je le souhaite parce que ça
me paraît fait essentiel pour maintenir
effectivement une gouvernance équilibrée
entre le département qui a des
ressources limitées pour le RSA vous le
savez puisque certains d'ailleurs l'ont
redéler à l'état et puis effectivement
les organismes compétents merci beaucoup
autant de Lefebvre merci madame la
Présidente l'ambition portée par le
gouvernement dans ce texte est noble et
j'en salue bien naturellement l'objectif
poursuivi mais la façon de remplir ses
objectifs peut paraître plus discutable
sur certains points les réseaux
d'émission locale ont fait part lors de
l'annonce de ce projet de loi de leur
crainte de se voir réduite à de simples
béquilles d'un opérateur
considérablement plus puissant sur le
territoire et voué sur le long terme a
absorbé la majeure partie de leur
pouvoir public de leur public pardon et
leur prérogative je tiens pourtant à
rappeler avec force que la gouvernance
des missions locales est administrée par
des élus locaux elle procède en cela
d'une proximité indispensable avec le
public jeune et éloigné de l'emploi qui
sont leur cœur de cible depuis 2001 j'ai
la chance de présider la Mission Locale
du Pays du Grand Lannoy et je mesure
combien celle-ci savent se placer au
plus près de ces jeunes elles savent
d'où ils viennent connaissent leur
milieu familial et leur environnement il
est trompeurs de considérer qu'une super
structure telle que France travaille
sera se substituer pleinement à la
mission d'accompagnement des publics
vers l'insertion dans l'emploi y compris
dans tous les recoins et tous les angles
morts que la diversité de ces profils
comporte en cela les
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre donc cet article que nous
allons examiner dans le cadre d'un
nouveau titre porte donc sur la création
du réseau France travail je souhaitais
pouvoir intervenir concernant le
thématique de la gouvernance car
effectivement on a tout d'abord
l'impression que la concertation qui
avait été engagée n'a pas servi à grand
chose puisque le projet de loi ne
reprend même pas les propositions
décentralisatrices contenues dans le
rapport guili contrairement à ce que
vous nous dites monsieur le ministre on
a déjà évoqué hier il s'agit bien d'un
texte recentralisateur qui entraîne une
nouvelle perte de compétences des
régions notamment tout simplement parce
que la compétence exclusive des régions
sur la formation professionnelle des
demandeurs d'emploi
issus de 40 ans de décentralisation je
le rappelle devient une compétence
partagée est en région les régions ainsi
craignent de ne plus être demain que de
simples opérateur de l'État via les
pattes régionaux d'investissement dans
les compétences dont la deuxième
génération est annoncée à partir de 2024
les régions pour autant pourtant pardon
ne cesse d'innover de créer des
dispositifs adaptés à leur territoire
avec l'ensemble des acteurs du service
public de l'emploi c'est dans cette
capacité d'adaptation au territoire aux
enjeux économiques je rappelle que les
régions la compétence du développement
économique aux enjeux sociaux
géographiques que résident les solutions
pour lever les freins à l'emploi la
standardisation de la gouvernance des
outils et des méthodes n'est jamais
porteuse de solutions adaptées face à la
singularité de chaque bassin de vie et
d'emploi
Monique le bain
oui monsieur le ministre moi je ne
comprends pas très bien ou vous voulez
en venir alors sur le projet de loi de
manière générale et mais où vous voulez
en venir par rapport à cette nouvelle
gouvernance vous parlez de de
[Musique]
redonner on va dire ou de rassembler des
gens qui travaillent déjà ensemble
je sais pas ce que ça a de rigolo je
vous parlais de faire travailler des
gens qui travaillent déjà ensemble
partout dans tous les départements qui
veulent bien s'en donner la peine il y a
des réseaux et Pôle emploi l'émission
locale les CAP EMPLOI travaillent déjà
ensemble donc là quel est l'objectif
c'est de créer une une espèce d'usine à
gaz ou finalement tout le monde perdra
un petit peu de ses spécificités moi je
trouve dommage qu'on ne laisse pas à
chacun exercer les métiers qu'ils savent
déjà exercer et j'ai une question qui
vous a déjà été posée de nombreuses fois
mais nous n'avons toujours pas la
réponse où sont les moyens parce que
pour accompagner mieux il faut des
moyens
ou alors on laisse les gens faire ce
qu'ils savent faire ou alors on crée un
nouvel organisme mais moi et sans
vouloir absolument pas revenir sur les
compétences des uns et des autres mais
je ne suis pas certaine qu'aujourd'hui
tous les opérateurs qui travaillent à
Pôle Emploi sont en capacité
d'accompagner des personnes handicapées
ou des personnes qui recherchent qui
sont privées d'emploi depuis très très
longtemps ou des personnes qui cumulent
plusieurs freins donc je ne comprends
pas l'objectif de cette nouvelle
gouvernance qui revient à finalement à
détruire quelque chose qui fonctionne
déjà très bien
monsieur le ministre
merci madame la Présidente de réponse
aux différentes interventions d'abord à
l'attention de Monsieur Lefebvre pour la
question des missions locales je l'ai
dit hier dans le texte il n'y a pas une
seule disposition qui modifie le statut
d'émission locale pas une seule
disposition qui modifie leur gouvernance
et pas une seule modification seul
disposition qui modifie leur mode de
financement l'émission locale
aujourd'hui conventionne financièrement
avec l'État et l'État apporte en moyenne
70% des financements qui permettent aux
missions locales de fonctionner ça sera
toujours le cas et le commencement aura
lieu directement avec l'État et ce que
je dis pour l'émission locale et valable
aussi pour les structures d'insertion
par l'activité économique Pôle emploi
qui a vocation de venir France travail
mais c'est un débat Pôle Emploi
aujourd'hui est un opérateur et il n'y a
pas de disposition qui prévoit un
conventionnement financier entre
l'émission locale et cette opérateur
dans ce cas il y aurait une forme de
subordination nous avons veillé à ce que
ça ne soit pas le cas donc les élus
resteront à la gouvernance des missions
locales et les missions locales gardent
leur statut et gardent leur autonomie je
sais très bien je l'ai dit hier aussi
qu'il y a 6 ou 7 ans un débat avait eu
lieu sur l'opportunité d'absorber
l'émission locale au sein de Pôle Emploi
ça n'est pas à l'ordre du jour ça n'est
plus à l'ordre du jour et nous avons
veillé à ce que ça ne soit pas le cas
c'est un projet que nous ne partageons
pas et que nous ne voulons pas mettre en
œuvre je dis et je dis en insistant sur
le fait que au cours des trois dernières
années l'État a confié aux missions
locales les deux tiers de son dispositif
le plus important en matière de jeunesse
le contrat engagement jeune 300 000
contrats au niveau national 200 000
portés par l'émission locale et ça s'est
traduit par le PDF 2023 avec des crédits
à destination des missions locales qui
dépassent les 600 millions d'euros et
vous savez que c'est un montant qui
n'avait jamais été atteint et qui
accompagne le dispositif de contre
engagement jeune donc soyez me rassuré
si je puis dire j'ajoute un point que
j'ai aussi souligné hier dans un
avant-projet dans une version de
l'avant-projet de loi il était précisé
que l'émission locale accueillerait les
jeunes par délégation de France travail
nous avons supprimé cette mention de
délégation et l'Union nationale des
missions locales dans son lors de son
bureau du 31 mai à souligner
sa satisfaction de que cette mention
soit supprimée ça répondait à son
inquiétude au-delà des dispositions et
des discussions que nous avons pu avoir
sur la question des régions évoquées par
Madame Ferret il y a un instant là aussi
madame la sénatrice aucune disposition
du texte absolument aucune ne remet en
cause la compétence des régions sur la
formation et en particulier sur la
formation des demandeurs d'emploi nous
souhaitons que le comité régional France
travaille soit qu'au président par le
préfet de région et par le président de
région mais ce comité ne décidera pas de
la politique formation de la région
c'est un comité qui a vocation comme à
tous les niveaux de la gouvernance de
France travail de définir des
orientations des priorités y compris les
priorités de Pôle emploi de les partager
mais ça ne revient pas sur la
répartition des compétences et je vous
assure que vous ne trouverez pas dans le
texte et vous l'avez vu vous l'avez
vérifié vous ne trouverez pas de
disposition qui viennent remettre en
cause la question les compétences des
régions mais ce que je dis pour les
régions est vrai pour les autres niveaux
de collectivité j'ai même le dire comme
je l'ai dit devant la commission des
affaires sociales et je crois que vous
étiez là
le gouvernement est votre serviteur en
tout premier lieu c'est que au Sénat le
gouvernement n'a pas de majorité pour
modifier la répartition des compétences
entre l'État et les collectivités
locales et comme je ne suis pas tout à
fait kamikaze je n'allais pas vous
proposer des dispositions venant sur ce
terrain là c'est la raison pour laquelle
le texte maintient les compétences des
uns et des autres et de la co-présidence
du comité d'orientation au niveau
régional ne vaut pas empiètement sur les
compétences des collectivités et enfin
un point sur la question des moyens mais
je l'ai dit aussi dans la commission des
affaires sociales nous avons en matière
moyen deux outils d'intervention le
projet de loi de finance qui va venir et
qui va permettre de conforter les
crédits notamment pour renforcer les
moyens des départements en matière
d'insertion si l'État depuis 2004
quel que soit les majorités avaient été
tout à fait exemplaire sur le respect de
la répartition 55 ans du montant du RSA
auprès des départements peut-être que
nous serions dans une autre disposition
ça n'est pas le cas personne ne l'a été
et donc dans ce cas-là il faut que nous
puissions aller vers la lettre au
département pour accompagner l'insertion
la majorité que je représente
aujourd'hui a proposé la
recentralisation pour des départements
volontaires et nous travaillons sur la
base de volontariat c'est le cas en
Seine-Saint-Denis c'est le cas notamment
dans les Hautes-Pyrénées et d'autres
départements nous ont dit leur intérêt
mais c'est uniquement sur la base du
volontariat et puis il y a un deuxième
moyen de financer France travail c'est
de financer l'opérateur qui a vocation à
renforcer suivi notamment
professionnelle aujourd'hui Pôle emploi
il y a une convention très particulière
et Pôle emploi aujourd'hui qui doit être
vu d'ici la fin de l'année et dans le
cadre de cette convention d'ores et déjà
11% des recettes de lunettes sont
utilisées pour financer le
fonctionnement de Pôle emploi la seule
dynamique salariale que nous connaissons
permet d'envisager pour 2024
une augmentation de cette fraction à ton
constant de 400 millions d'euros mais en
réalité il faut aller un peu plus loin
je crois et je suis convaincu je l'ai
dit hier aussi qu'en matière de lutte
contre le chômage et donc de formation
des demandeurs d'emploi pour lutter plus
efficacement contre le chômage ça
s'appelle d'une certaine manière des
dépenses actives et que la discussion
avec les parties prenantes de cette
convention tripartite doit aussi nous
permettre d'avancer et de garantir ce
financement nous aurons donc deux
rendez-vous la négociation très partie
et le PLF pour faire en sorte que les
moyens prévus pour la montée en charge
progressive j'insiste parce que nous ne
basculerons pas du suivi intensif de 40
000 allocataires dans le cadre de
l'expérimentation à un million 950 000
entre la nuit du 31 décembre 2023 et le
1er janvier 2024 mais que cette montée
en puissance progressive puisse être
financée comme le gouvernement s'y est
engagé
[Musique]
merci madame laquoisillante monsieur le
ministre cet amendement donc vise à
supprimer l'article 4 la création du
nouvel opérateur France travail affiche
un objectif qui semble simple parvenir
au plein emploi d'ici 2027 l'objectif
peut être a priori et consensuel nous
l'avons déjà dit cependant la méthode ne
les beaucoup moins en effet France
travail agirait pour trouver les 5,1
millions de personnes or radar qui ne
seraient pas insérés dans le monde du
travail et les dispositions prévues pour
la création du nouvel opérateur et du
réseau France travail ils sont flous
elle témoigne d'une volonté non
seulement de recentralisation qui
viendrait standardiser la gouvernance et
ses outils contre des logiques qui
prévalaient jusqu'à lors de
territorialisation et d'adaptation par
les acteurs locaux les compétences en
matière d'insertion d'accompagnement de
département de formation et
d'orientation professionnelle des
régions ne doivent pas être remises en
cause par la création du réseau France
travail et puis bien sûr la question des
moyens ça a été évoqué déjà par
plusieurs de mes collègues rien n'est
ici précisé
pour l'identique madame ponce de 499
merci madame la Présidente la nouvelle
gouvernance prévue par l'article 4
inclut l'article L
5311-4 ou figure explicitement les
entreprises de travail temporaire cette
intégration pose problème pour deux
raisons principales que je souhaite
développer tout d'abord se pose la
question quand même de la sécurisation
de données transmise à des entreprises
et donc des risques d'utilisation de ces
données à d'autres fins que celles qui
sont initialement prévues il y a donc un
risque d'un relatif conflit d'intérêt de
plus l'influence des organismes au sein
de la gouvernance c'est également un
point de cet article qui inclut donc les
entreprises de travail temporaire dont
la participation pour élaborer des
indicateurs communs de suivi de pilotage
et d'évaluation la participation
d'entreprise du secteur privé a bu
lucratif à la définition des indicateurs
de France travail et la nouvelle
fonction de repérage en plus du suivi de
ces opérateurs privés présentent un
risque de privatisation croissante du
service public de l'emploi avec la
possibilité d'élégation de tout parti
ces missions au secteur privé lucratifs
en conséquence et pour d'autres raisons
mais en conséquence cet amendement du
groupe écologiste a pour objet la
suppression de l'article 4 la commission
merci madame la Présidente
alors ça sera un avis défavorable à ses
amendements de suppression puisque la
Commission a adopté l'article 4 en y
apportant d'importantes modifications
tout d'abord une mission de réponse aux
besoins des employeurs à signer au
réseau France travail un renforcement
des prérogatives du Comité National
France travail afin qu'ils se prononce
de manière concertée sur l'ensemble des
critères et outils communs aux acteurs
du réseau sur les besoins de financement
qu'il constatera par les remontées du
terrain et sur l'interopérabilité des
systèmes d'information
nous avons aussi supprimé la charte
d'engagement car les collectivités ont
vocation à co présider les comités
territoriales sans signer de charte et
que les acteurs auront déjà à s'engager
sans imposer ce document par la loi
et aussi le renforcement du rôle des
élus locaux dans les communes les
comités locaux donc voilà compte tenu de
ces apports la Commission souhaite
l'adoption de cet article 4 et donc avis
défavorable sur ces amendements ministre
même avis je mets aux voix qui est pour
Monsieur Savary pardon oui merci
c'est bien merci Madame leur rapporteur
d'avoir supprimé effectivement cette
charte d'engagement parce que sinon la
charte ça voulait dire une contrainte de
chaque collectivité dans le cadre de ses
responsabilités de participer justement
au financement des actions pour
lesquelles il se réunissent
vous faites un peu dur en même temps là
monsieur
le ministre en même temps on touche pas
aux compétences des collectivités on dit
tout surtout pas mais en réorganise
quand même les coordination de tout ça
nous on avait opté au Sénat
rappelez-vous c'est déjà un peu ancien
mais il y a quelques anciens parmi nous
quand même nous avions opté nous avions
opté dans la loi nôtre pour une région
analysation à la fois de la politique de
la formation de l'insertion et du
Travail de l'Emploi c'est une voie que
vous auriez pu suivre qui était une voix
effectivement qui donnait une confiance
aux opérateurs du territoire chacun dans
leur domaine de compétence
vous n'avez pas choisi vous avez choisi
une voie qui est une voie un peu
intermédiaire c'est pour ça le bien
entendu mais il n'empêche que c'est une
voie difficile parce que les choses vont
pas tout à fait comme on le souhaiterait
sinon on serait pas réunis ici et vous
pensez que en modifiant l'organisation
venant d'en haut disant voilà vous allez
vous organiser comme ça ça va mieux
marcher
je reste dubitatif heureusement que il y
a eu des modifications à porter par la
commission sinon je ne suis pas sûr que
j'aurais voté cet article parce que si
vous prenez les mêmes on essaye bien sûr
de les remettre dans le bon sens mais
rien ne change par rapport à la
répartition de tout ça je suis pas sûr
qu'on arrive quand même à un résultat
qui soit celui que vous envisagez
aujourd'hui de plein emploi donc
allons-y parce qu'il faut quand même
essayer on peut pas rester dans le statu
quo on en est tous d'accord allons-y
soyez attentif quand même monsieur le
ministre au décrépris de façon à ce que
ça réussisse parce que c'est ce qui
importe dans ce texte de loi quand même
je vais donc mettre au voie puisqu'il y
a d'autres explication de vote qui est
pour double avis défavorable pardon qui
est pour
quiconque s'abstient ils ne sont pas
adoptés le 174 madame pansement
oui merci la Présidente
j'ai déjà évoqué ce sujet mais j'y
reviens monsieur le ministre cette loi
est une loi d'emploi d'ailleurs elle
s'appelle pleine emploi donc vous avez
pour cela écoutez comme Depuis 40 ans
les écoute d'ailleurs les économistes de
l'emploi qui vous donnent toujours les
mêmes recettes voilà mais cette fois-ci
avec le RSA avec les allocataires du RSA
vous comptez vous vous appuyez sur des
économistes de l'emploi pour régler une
question sociale et là il y a un vrai
problème et en toute état de cause vous
ne tirez pas le bilan de 40 ans de loi
focalisé sur l'emploi et notre étang
jamais du travail alors vraiment
j'insiste quand même il n'y a aucune
raison que votre réseau s'appelle
le réseau France travail enfin vraiment
d'ailleurs je vous le fais remarquer
dans votre ministère vous vous appelez
bien ministre de l'Emploi du travail
donc il y a bien une différence donc là
alors que vous faites une loi plein
emploi vous appelez un réseau France
France travail donc genre j'aurais été
le fait que le terme de travail est
usurpé et qu'effectivement le grand
problème de tout ça c'est que comme pour
la retraite et bien vous ne traitez pas
la question du travail vous me traitez
pas à la question de l'attractivité des
métiers de la tractivité des emplois qui
sont durablement vacantes ce que vous
faites c'est que vous contraignez des
personnes à y rentrer mais ça sera assez
vain je vous rendez vous dans quelques
années pour le la énième loi qui viendra
essayer de renoncer à ça vous traitez
pas de la crise du travail vous traitez
de rien des questions
contemporaines qui traversent pourtant
tous les penseurs toutes les études et
vous vous nous faites une énième loi en
poids voilà donc appeler les lois au
moins on dit toujours que mal nommer les
choses c'est c'est accroître la misère
du monde
appelez votre réseau France emploi
de la Commission
c'est la vie constant sur sur ses
amendements que notre collègue a déposé
plusieurs fois déjà donc c'est un avis
défavorable puisque la commission elle a
fait le choix de maintenir le nom de
Pôle emploi et de laisser au seul réseau
l'appellation France travail
quand même ma vie
je mets aux voix double avis défavorable
qui est pour qui contre qui s'abstient
pas adopter le 503 madame poncer
l'article elle 5311 4 intègre les
entreprises de travail temporaire dans
le service public de l'emploi
au même titre que les associations
d'insertion sociale ou que les
organismes de placement spécialisés dans
l'insertion professionnelle des
personnes handicapées pourtant les
agences d'intérim neuvent qu'une
plus-value limitée aux tensions durable
du marché du travail et si elles peuvent
parfois offrir des solutions d'appoint
elles ne correspondent pas aux missions
du service public de l'emploi défini par
le code du travail notamment les notions
de sécurisation du parcours
professionnel qui suppose des emplois
durables la baisse du chômage
effectivement était effective mais elle
est en trompe l'oeil les déclarations
d'embauche pour les CDD de moins d'un
mois tirant à la hausse des embouts les
embauches globales alors vous nous dit
que la dernière mois il y avait 50% en
CDI il n'en reste pas moins que les
statistiques encore montrent que ce sont
les CDD de moins d'un mois qui tirent à
la hausse les embauches globales c'est
des données statistiques les
allocataires du RSA qui constituent la
nouvelle cible du gouvernement pour
améliorer l'appariement avec les emplois
durablement vacants sont déjà largement
en intérim ils sont déjà largement en
emploi précaires c'est ce qui fait leur
va-et-vient ce qui précisément d'après
la Cour des comptes pour y écouter la
Cour des comptes quand même et la DARES
alimentent la précarité 17% d'entre eux
sont contrats temporaire il n'y a que 5
% de la population qui sont dans ce cas
c'est un manquement d'appel vise donc à
affirmer qu'il est impératif de lutter
contre la précarisation des demandeurs
d'emploi et aujourd'hui des allocataires
du RSA que le présent projet de loi ne
fera renforcer la mission du service
public de l'emploi doit être orienté sur
l'accompagnement le soutien à la levée
des freins mais le retour à un emploi
durable c'est ce que disent d'ailleurs
les partenaires de l'unédique que ce qui
les intéresse c'est le retour à un
emploi durable et non servir à
l'amplification des trappes à précarité
en favorisant l'orientation des
demandeurs d'emploi dans l'intérim ou
les métiers en tension c'est pourquoi
nous jugeons qui est essentiel de sortir
les entreprises de travail temporaires
du service public de l'emploi quelle est
la ville de la commission madame la
rapporteur
merci madame le Président de mes
Présidente c'est un avis défavorable
n'est pas justifiée aujourd'hui de
supprimer les entreprises de travail
temporaire de la liste des membres du
service public de l'emploi et du réseau
France travail on a déjà besoin je pense
de beaucoup en fait de
d'instance qui puisse accompagner les
personnes vers l'emploi et je rappelle
je rappelle que ces entreprises
contribuent largement à l'emploi dans
notre pays fin 2023
792600 personnes
occupent un emploi intérimaire et si
effectivement au départ c'est de
l'intérim pour beaucoup à un moment
donné ils intègrent bien entendu
l'emploi durable donc elles sont aussi
très utiles dans le parcours d'insertion
de recherche d'emploi et dans des
accompagnements adaptés aux besoins de
la personne donc il y a aucune raison
franchement d'écarter ces entreprises
c'est donc un avis défavorable ministre
même avis
je vais mettre au western amendement et
double avis défavorable qui est pour
quiconque qui appartient il n'est pas
adopté mes chers collègues en votre nom
j'ai le plaisir de saluer la présence
dans les tribunes de nord d'une
délégation de la Chambre des
représentants de la Malaisie conduite
par son Président
Monsieur tanzry Abdul et composé de 4
présidents de commissions de cet
assemblée la délégation est accompagnée
par notre collègue Mathieu Darnaud
président du groupe d'amitié France Asie
du Sud-Est ainsi que notre collègue
Jean-Michel Houlgate président délégué
pour la Malaisie la délégation est en
visite en France pour développer les
relations de la Malaisie avec notre pays
et plus largement avec l'Union
européenne cette visite fait suite à la
mission du groupe d'amitié à Kuala
Lumpur est dans le sultanat du Peyrac en
mai 2022 qui a permis de renforcer les
liens entre nos deux Parlement la
Malaisie pour la France un partenaire
privilégié dans l'Indopacifique avec
lequel nous avons vocation à développer
de nouveaux projets de coopération mes
chers collègues permettez-moi de
souhaiter en votre nom à tous à nos
homologues du Parlement malaisien la
plus grande galerie ainsi qu'un
excellent et fructueux séjour
[Applaudissements]
et nous passons à l'amendement 307 de
Madame Ferré
merci Madame la cohésion monsieur le
ministre cet amendement vise à intégrer
les Plans Locaux pluriannuels pour
l'insertion de l'emploi les plis et les
maisons de l'emploi parmi les acteurs
membres du réseau France travail le bloc
communal en particulier les
intercommunalités concourent au service
public de l'emploi en président et en
finançant des opérateurs et organismes
divers donc plus de 75 maisons de
l'emploi et plus de 130 plis
alors quelle est la ville de la
Commission sur cet amendement
est pleinement satisfait nous l'avons
déjà dit d'ailleurs plusieurs fois car
le texte prévoit que les plis et les
maisons de l'emploi seront membres du
réseau et la Commission à modifier le
texte en ce sens pour bien le préciser
et les orités et les autorités et
organismes compétents en matière
d'insertion sociale et professionnelle
pourront également être membres du
réseau donc c'est une demande de retrait
ou un avis défavorable monsieur le
ministre mais ma vie je mets aux voix
double vie défavorable qui est pour
Madame Ferrer il est retiré
et nous passons au 117 monsieur Chassin
président de madame le rapporteur donc
si vous voulez c'est une crainte
qui est relayée
des missions locales la dénomination
opérateur spécialisé employés dans le
présent projet de loi laisse supposer un
lien subordination des organismes placés
dans cette catégorie vis-à-vis de France
travail cet amendement vise à donner aux
missions le même angle opérateur France
travaille au réseau au sein du réseau
France travail je rappelle que
l'émission sont des acteurs les mieux
adaptés bien sûr pour accompagner des
jeunes pour les accueillir les orienter
les personnels les jeunes de l'ASEE
décrocheurs scolaires les
sous-mains de justice cet amendement a
simplement pour objectif de relayer des
craintes des responsables des missions
locales notamment sur le plan financier
merci
quelle est la vie de la Commission sur
cet amendement
merci même la présidente ce sera un avis
défavorable chers collègues parce que
bien entendu on entend bien que on veut
pas de lien de subordination au sein des
opérateurs de du réseau France travail
et donc pour Pôle emploi c'est la raison
aussi pour laquelle nous ne souhaitons
pas que Pôle Emploi prenne ce nom de
France travail en revanche la mission
d'accompagnement de public spécifique
tels que les jeunes en difficulté et les
personnes en situation de handicap
semble cohérent de les de qualifier
ainsi l'émission locale et les Cap
emploi puisque ce sont quand même des
opérateurs qui sont spécialisés
donc cette qualification elle
n'affaiblit en rien en fait les missions
de ces organismes donc c'est pour
laquelle c'est pour la raison pour
laquelle
demande de retrait ou un invité
favorable merci avis du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
c'est le même avis une demande de
retrait dans les différents échanges que
nous avons eu tant avec les
représentants de Cap emploi par ailleurs
opérateur spécialisé pour les personnes
en situation de handicap qu'avec les
représentants des missions locales c'est
une volonté aussi de montrer combien ils
étaient spécialisés justement sur
l'accueil d'un public en particulier en
l'occurrence les jeunes donc c'est une
demande de retrait car ça ne porte pas
préjudice au contraire c'est pour
marquer cette spécificité
il est retiré nous passons maintenant 9
amendements commune et on commence avec
le 505 de Madame ponce
oui c'est bien dommage que c'est été
retiré parce qu'effectivement les
craintes de la Mission locale ont des
fondements quand même et si vous voulez
vraiment lever ça fait un déjà un
contrat pluriel de financement à la
prochaine loi de financement là ici il
s'agit de proposer la création d'une
instance nationale qui aura pour
notamment pour rôle de définir les
critères d'orientation or il semble que
la définition des communs des
référentiels des critères d'orientation
ne peut s'effectuer sans la
participation à minima pour avis des
principaux organismes chargés de
l'accompagnement des personnes les plus
éloignées de l'emploi et des
allocataires du RSA ils sont vraiment
incontournables pour la création de
référentiel comme impertinent je pense
que notre débat d'ailleurs en montre la
nécessité prenant en compte la totalité
de la réalité de l'accompagnement de ces
personnes ainsi que pour identifier
leurs besoins d'accompagnement
d'orientation de façon pertinente et
puis aussi l'interopérabilité des
systèmes le danger par exemple qui a
constitué l'orientation algorithmique et
bien établie par la Cour des comptes à
partir de l'exemple de certains
départements qui ont eu massivement
recours tels que la Seine-Saint-Denis ou
la qualité de l'orientation qui résulte
de la mise en oeuvre du traitement
algorithmique et remise en cause par les
conseillers d'incertion par les
travailleurs sociaux également par Pôle
emploi par ailleurs la délégation par
les départements de la compagnement à
Pôle emploi est un phénomène de plus en
plus prégnant or cette décharge s'avère
souvent inadaptée donc l'opérateur
estime que dans certains cas une prise
en charge de problématique de santé
serait effectivement aurait été
nécessaire cet amendement se propose
donc d'inclure des représentants des
unions et fédérations représentant les
structures d'insertion et
d'accompagnement des demandeurs d'emploi
au sein du Comité National de France
travail en leur offrant une voix
consultative
merci en pas de vous identiques monsieur
girl le 91 merci Madame à la présidente
les entreprises adaptées représentent un
levier d'inclusion extraordinaire par
l'emploi des personnes en situation de
handicap en milieu ordinaire ces
entreprises tentent à développer
notamment par le biais d'expérimentation
l'accompagnement des transitions
professionnelles des personnes en
situation de handicap et leur mobilité
vers d'autres entreprises et le
constituent également un vivier de
ressources humaines et de compétences au
service des métiers en tension telles
que la Restauration il existe un
paradoxe entre le nombre de personnes en
situation de handicap inscrite à Pôle
emploi et les difficultés de recrutement
persistantes exprimées par les trois
quarts des Entreprises Adaptées la
complexité de l'identification de
l'évaluation du handicap par l'ensemble
des acteurs ne permettent pas à ces
personnes d'accéder à l'emploi hauteur
du besoin aussi afin de faciliter
l'emploi et l'insertion des travailleurs
handicapés la présence des représentants
des entreprises adaptées au sein de
France travail permettrait une meilleure
reprise en compte des spécificités
afférentes c'est amendement vise donc à
que les entreprises adaptées soient
partie intégrante du réseau France
travail et prennent pas à sa gouvernance
nationale notamment par le biais de
l'Union nationale des entreprises
adaptées qui représentent 75% des
entreprises adaptées
est défendu merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre aujourd'hui les
représentants des pardon des Entreprises
Adaptées ne sont pas présents dans les
différents comités du service public de
l'emploi aussi bien nationalement que
localement donc l'amendement que nous
proposons vise donc à ce que ces
entreprises adaptées soient parties
intégrante du réseau France travail et
prennent pas à ce gouvernance national
en effet les entreprises adaptées sur
des composantes essentiels des
politiques publiques du handicap preuve
en est l'engagement national de cap vers
l'entreprise inclusive 2018-2022 qui
fixait conformément la volonté du
gouvernement de réduire le chômage des
personnes handicapées un objectif de
40000 créations d'emplois c'était donc
l'objectif par le secteur adapté les
entreprises adaptées sont un levier
d'inclusion par l'emploi des personnes
en situation de handicap de handicap en
milieu ordinaire aussi en fin de
faciliter l'emploi en insertion de ces
travailleurs handicapés la présence des
représentants des entreprises adaptées
au sein de France travail permettrait
une meilleure prise en compte des
spécificités afférentes merci le 93
monsieur Guillaume
poursuit le même objectif que le
précédent il propose que les entreprises
adaptées soient partie intégrante du
réseau France travail et prennent pas à
sa gouvernance nationale
merci Monsieur Chassin pour le 139
identique
madame la Présidente du ministre donc
c'est le même amendement sous les
simplement par répéter tout ce qui a été
dit mais il existe un paradoxe entre le
nombre de personnes en situation du
handicap inscrite à Pôle emploi et les
difficultés de recrutement persistants
exprimé dans 75% des Entreprises
Adaptées c'est la complexité de
l'identification et d'évaluation du
handicap par l'ensemble des acteurs ne
permettent pas à ces personnes d'accéder
à l'emploi à l'auteur des besoins c'est
pour ça que je me rallie bien sûr à ce
qui vient d'être dit par mes deux
collègues il serait important que les
entreprises adaptées soient partie
intégrante du réseau France travail
merci merci
nous sommes dans cet amendement toujours
sur la même demande et je considère
qu'il est défendu monsieur le ministre
le 624 identique
si vous me permettez madame la prison je
présente le 624 ce qui me permet de
donner mon avis sur les autres pour dire
que l'amendement de Madame ponce de 505
et satisfait puisque les différents
acteurs que vous citez madame la
sénatrice sont citées notamment aux
articles
l53117 du Code du travail ainsi que 53
11-4 comme soit structures délégatures
des conseils départementaux soit comme
organisme public juste vous présenter
votre amendement parce qu'on a encore
d'autres derrière qui n'ont pas été
présentés donc c'était pour gagner du
temps
donc c'est simplement pour sur
l'amendement mais je reviendrai pour
Madame ponce l'amendement que je
présente vise à intégrer les entreprises
adaptées qui sont les seules organismes
à ne pas être membre du réseau si on
s'en tient au référence des textes la
seule différence avec les autres
amendements qui vont dans le même sens
est une différence rédactionnelle et
donc c'est pour ça qu'ils ont présenté
cet amendement 624
[Musique]
que le 91 93 le 312 madame poumon
madame Ferrer pardon
toujours dans la même lignée les défendu
très bien merci quelle est la vie de
Madame la rapporteur sur ses amendements
merci madame la Présidente alors sur
l'amendement 505 qui ajoute au sein du
réseau France travail des représentants
de structures d'insertion par l'activité
économique ça m'en demande est
pleinement satisfait donc c'est déjà
prévu
donc c'est une demande de retrait ou un
avis défavorable sur les autres
amendements qui ajoutent au sein de
réseau France travail des entreprises
adaptées et certaines prévoir aussi la
présence de représentations des
entreprises adaptées dans le Comité
National France travail nous pensions
que le texte permettait déjà d'inclure
les entreprises adaptées dans le réseau
France travail mais le gouvernement
semble considérer qu'il est plus sûr de
les mentionner expressément pension bien
sûr que ces structures doivent être
incluses dans le réseau donc pour des
raisons rédactionnelles je propose
l'adoption donc de l'amendement 624 du
gouvernement permettra aussi aux
Entreprises Adaptées d'être représentées
au Comité national en conséquence une
demande de retrait ou un avis
défavorable sur les autres amendements
qui deviendront satisfait par l'adoption
de celui du gouvernement voilà et le 309
de Madame Ferrer qui a été modifié est
identique à celui du gouvernement donc
c'est un avis favorable
monsieur le Miss j'ai bien compris vous
avez un allez-y dites-nous l'heure une
phrase
donc juste terminer ma réponse à Madame
pansement c'est satisfait parce que les
organismes que vous citez sont soit des
organismes d'accompagnement soit des
organismes d'élagataires donc c'est
couvert pour le reste madame le
rapporteur l'a dit la rédaction du 624
que je présente permet de sécuriser la
participation des entreprises adaptées
c'était le seul organisme qui
n'apparaissait pas comme explicitement
après relecture intégrée au Comité
national
résumé un avis favorable de
[Musique]
la
gants et donc un avis forme du
gouvernement sur le 309 qui est
identique aussi est-ce que vous
maintenez tous vos amendes moi est-ce
que vous retirez vous retirez on retire
tout vous retirez tout pardon et on
garde le 309 et le 624 qui ont un double
avis favorable monsieur gueule vous êtes
d'accord aussi avec tout cela c'est
formidable donc je soumets aux voix le
309 et le 624 double avis favorable qui
est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient et ils
sont adoptés et nous passons ensuite à
l'amendement 593 du gouvernement
rédactionnelle madame la rapporteur est
favorable si personne n'y voit
d'inconvénients il est adopté nous
passons ensuite aux 40 alors j'ai le
choix pour le défendre entre monsieur
Chassin monsieur mouiller qui était
toujours là qui défend le 40 madame
Berthet excusez-moi je ne vous voyais
pas vous étiez comme on dit comment on
dit dans l'angle mort de mon rétroviseur
d'accord très bien merci la présidente
monsieur le ministre madame le
rapporteur le rapport de la délégation
aux entreprises intitulées formées pour
aujourd'hui et pour demain les
compétences en jeu de croissance et de
société a révélé que l'on compte
aujourd'hui 120 métiers en tension
contre 50 en 2015 et 30 métiers
souffrent d'une réelle crise
d'attractivité liée à une méconnaissance
de la nature du métier ou une mauvaise
perception des opportunités réelles
qu'ils offrent
pourtant notre pays compte toujours 3
millions de chômeurs et 13% des jeunes
Français ne sont ni en étude ni en
emploi ni en formation parmi ces 30
propositions la délégation aux
entreprises a donc recommandé
d'améliorer la promotion des métiers en
tension et l'information des élèves tout
comme des demandeurs d'emploi à leur
sujet le présentement traduit cette
recommandation et propose d'intégrer
systématiquement au parcours
d'orientation et d'accompagnement des
demandeurs d'emploi une sensibilisation
opportunités offertes par les métiers en
tension permettant ainsi de mieux faire
connaître les débouchés les
rémunérations et les perspectives
offertes par ces métiers souvent
essentiels à la vie de notre nation
merci quelle est la vie de la Commission
merci madame la Présidente alors ce sera
un avis défavorable je sais que je vais
beaucoup décevoir mes collègues en
revanche bien sûr c'est très important
de sensibiliser les demandeurs d'emploi
aux opportunités offertes par les
métiers en tension la raison aussi pour
laquelle en fait on a bien indiqué que
les entreprises devaient être bien
les demandes des entreprises devaient
être tenu compte pour dans le réseau
pour répondre notamment à ses métiers en
tension mais pour autant en fait nous
sommes pas opportun d'assigner dans la
loi des missions aussi précises aux
réseaux France travail les précisions
doivent être fixées plutôt par les
référentiels et documents qui définiront
love de services des membres du réseau
France travail qui sont élaborés de
manière concertée par l'État les
partenaires sociaux et les collectivités
territoriales je pense que c'est
important que ce soit à ce niveau là que
ce soit décidé et non pas inscrit dans
la loi parce que si on inscrit dans la
loi ça on devrait en inscrire énormément
beaucoup et on va encore faire une loi
très bavard et on laissera moins de
souplesse en fait dans ce réseau où on
souhaite vraiment avoir un véritable
partenariat des véritables discussions
et puis spécialiser aussi finalement en
fonction des besoins de chacun
monsieur le ministre
merci madame la Présidente c'est
effectivement une proposition du rapport
que Madame Berthet nous a remis avec un
certain nombre de ses collègues le
rapport de la délégation fait de
nombreuses propositions qui vont dans le
bon sens il a été élaboré dans une
période assez concomitante à celle de
l'élaboration du projet de loi ce qui
explique que beaucoup des amendements
qui sont tirés de ce rapport sont issus
de ce rapport pardon sont satisfaits par
la loi ou relève parfois d'un niveau
réglementaire ou de la gestion en
l'occurrence pour ce qui concerne la
sensibilisation des demandeurs d'emploi
aux métiers en tension c'est la relève
de la gestion au-delà de ce que disait
madame la rapporteur sur les priorités
des comités locaux et à titre
d'illustration mais je l'ai partagé avec
vous Madame Monsieur matrice lorsque
nous nous sommes rencontrés pour le
rapport au mois d'octobre dernier j'ai
demandé aux différentes agences Pôle
emploi pour les 23 métiers les plus en
de tension dans un premier temps de
regarder liste demandeurs d'emploi par
liste de demandeurs d'emploi à l'échelle
des agences tous ceux qui avaient un
prérequis une compétence une expérience
leur permettant de se rapprocher de ces
secteurs en tension de tous les recevoir
individuellement et en gros pour
présenter les métiers en tension et les
sensibiliser et en cas
vision d'adhérence de les inscrire sur
un vivier de demandeur d'emploi pour ces
métiers en tension presque 200 000
personnes ont été inscrites 145 000 ont
été recrutés ce qui est plutôt un bon
résultat et depuis le 1er juin dernier
au premier mai pardon pour la précision
nous avons élargi cette liste de 23
métiers à l'ensemble des métiers de
l'industrie qui connaissent évidemment
des tensions mais aux 12 principaux
métiers de l'industrie donc c'est
quelque chose qui marche que nous
faisons en termes de gestion au sein de
Pôle emploi et qui pourrait être poussé
comme une priorité par les comités
locaux et régionaux mais qui ne nous
paraît pas relever de la loi de la
demande de retrait
je le retire mais vous nous présentez le
41 alors le 41 est défendu
ils sont pas en discussion commune
quelle est la vie de la commission sur
le 41 ils sont pas de discussions
communes madame la Présidente rapporteur
vous comprenez
vous adhérez merci même la présidente
est complètement ce sera un avis
défavorable parce que voilà lever les
freins à l'emploi c'est une évidence en
fait dans je dirais tout le texte de loi
si on lève pas les freins bien entendu
il y aura plus de difficultés à insérer
les personnes et les amener à l'emploi
donc c'est un avis vraiment défavoré
défavorable mais en revanche on en tient
compte bien évidemment une liste même à
vivre madame Berthet oui je le retire et
comme hier je précise que c'est mieux
quand même quand c'est écrit voilà et le
42 alors le 42
alors même qu'elle est essentielle pour
former à de nombreux métiers en tension
et métiers d'avenir la voix
professionnelle connaît aujourd'hui
d'importantes difficultés elle est
perçue comme insuffisamment attirante
insuffisamment professionnalisante et
surtout insuffisamment insérantes comme
la démontrer notre dernière rapport la
voie professionnelle accueille un lycéen
sur 3 mais c'est 61% du décrochage des
jeunes qui intervient au sein des lycées
professionnels pire encore près d'un
diplômé un diplômé de cap sur deux n'a
toujours pas trouvé d'emplois stable
deux ans après la fin de ses études par
conséquent le rapport de la délégation
préconise de confier au service public
de l'emploi la mission d'accompagner ses
lycéens un peu avant et jusqu'à deux ans
après l'obtention de leur diplôme il
faut intensifier l'accompagnement de ces
jeunes qui représentent un potentiel
énorme pour notre société et notre
économie avant que n’intervienne ne
décrochage auquel il est ensuite
extrêmement difficile de remédier c'est
l'objet donc du présent à
oui merci même la Présidente je vais
encore décevoir ma collègue moi aussi je
fais la délégation aux entreprises et
bien sûr je participais à des auditions
et lu les rapports donc bien sûr sur sur
ce que vous dites et sur l'importance
d'assurer le suivi l'accompagnement vers
l'emploi des lycées de la voie
professionnelle on vous rejoint
totalement mais c'est aussi le cas des
jeunes qui ne passent pas par les lycées
professionnels les jeunes en
apprentissage les jeunes décrocheurs les
jeunes diplômés etc c'est pourquoi la
Commission a précisé dans le texte de
manière plus générale que les missions
du réseau France travaille seront
réalisés en lien avec le service public
de l'éducation a été vraiment ajouté et
compte tenu des différents publications
plus larges que les seuls lycées un
professionnel il est aussi préférable de
laisser les acteurs sur le terrain
identifier les personnes prioritaires en
fonction des situations locales et des
bassins d'emplois sans trop figer les
choses dans la loi donc c'est une
demande de retrait ou un avis
défavorable
monsieur le ministre même avis madame
Berthet que faites-vous
je vais le retirer merci Madame pensez
monche c'est à vous pour le 508 que vous
n'allez pas
mes présidentes alors le présent projet
de loi prévoit la mise en place
d'indicateurs il y a les instances de
gouvernement de France travail mais sans
en préciser aucun son procédé alors donc
du coup à l'analyse et au bilan de la
précédente fusion de l'ANPE et des
ASSEDIC qui a vous le savez dégradé
l'accompagnement social en permettant
aussi l'explosion du portefeuille des
conseillers Pôle Emploi selon le CESU un
agent accompagné en moyenne 86
demandeurs d'emploi en janvier 2009
j'oser les chiffres d'aujourd'hui je
n'ose rappeler le député Stéphane Viry
dans une mission d'information flash sur
Pôle emploi en 2019 faisait déjà état de
portefeuilles surdimensionnés en
précisant que la situation est
fidelitaire que les agents ont
intériorisés ont appris à vivre avec la
pénurie d'effectif donc sans l'inclusion
quand même d'indicateurs un minimum
d'indicateurs pour maintenir un niveau
de portefeuille raisonnable et suivez
protéger les conditions de travail des
conseillers il sera impossible
d'accompagner ce qu'on entend depuis
hier efficacement les demandeurs
d'emploi et des vider et d'éviter une
dégradation supplémentaire des
conditions de travail avec la prise en
charge de centaines d'allocataires du
RSA non inscrit à ce jour il est donc
impératif comme le propose c'est
amendement d'intégrer dans les
indicateurs un minimum de d'objectifs y
compris un objectif quand même de simple
réduction des portefeuilles via
notamment une augmentation des effectifs
et en tenant compte aussi des disparités
territoriales puisqu'il y a des
disparités territoriales je lisait
dernièrement la présence de Pôle emploi
dans les quartiers Didi ficide qui est
effectivement
inférieur à d'autres d'autres
territoires je rappelle pas la
comparaison sur l'Allemagne et ses
effectifs donc les indicateurs doivent
quand même on va pas rester dans le flou
autrement il y aura rien on doit quand
même mesurer l'accompagnement social
pour lever pour l'accompagnement social
et lever les freins à l'emploi pour
l'accompagnement à l'autonomie le retour
un emploi durable il nous faut ce
minimum d'indicateurs qui ont garanti au
moins les moyens
quelle est la ville de la Commission
défavorable parce qu'il est pas
souhaitable d'apporter des précisions
aussi détaillées sur la nature le type
des indicateurs communs de suivi de
pilotage qui seront élaborés par les
membres du réseau France travail
devront définir par les comités de
manière concertée afin qu'il soit adapté
aux besoins et aux réalités je pense
qu'on peut faire un petit peu confiance
en fait à cette nouvelle gouvernance qui
est je le rappelle l'État les
collectivités territoriales et les
partenaires sociaux voilà donc avis
défavorable
quelle est la vie du gouvernement mais
ma vie je mets aux voix qui est pour qui
contre qui absorbe n'est pas adopté
monsieur le ministre le 595 c'est
vous merci madame la Présidente c'est un
amendement pour lequel je crains avoir
un succès d'estime puisqu'il s'agit de
rétablir la charte d'engagement que
Monsieur Savary évoquait tout à l'heure
la charte d'engagement que nous avions
prévu dans le texte initial en cadre les
modalités notamment des changes de
données d'accès au système d'information
ce n'est pas une remise en cause de
l'autonomie ou on s'en fout j'ai entendu
les inquiétudes qui avaient été
exprimées j'ai aussi vu le nombre
d'amendements qui avaient été déposés en
commission pour proposer sa suppression
donc je propose son rétablissement pour
le bon fonctionnement du système que
nous proposons
quelle est la vie de la Commission sur
cet amendement du Gouvernement
dit madame la Présidente je dirais
monsieur le ministre c'est bien tenté
la commission elle a supprimé la charte
d'engagement pour plusieurs raisons en
fait
l'article 4 prévoit déjà que les acteurs
du réseau France travaille devront
conduire des actions coordonnées et
complémentaires et qu'ils devront mettre
en œuvre un socle commun de service
élaboré des indicateurs communs de suivi
de pilotage partagez des informations
assurer l'interopérabilité de leur
système d'information cette charte n'est
donc pas utile alors même que les
comités France travail définiront de
manière concertée des orientations et
des outils communs et il est préférable
qu'il ne soit pas contraint par une
charte avant même de définir ces outils
alors je note que le gouvernement ne
rétablit pas l'obligation faite aux
collectivités de signer la charte pour
que leur président qu'au président les
comités territoriaux ça c'était un
irritant
nous avions considéré que cette
disposition qui était dans le texte
initial n'était vraiment pas acceptable
les collectivités territoriales
disposent de compétences propres en
matière d'emploi et d'insertion au titre
desquels elles ont vocation dans tous
les cas prendre par aux instances de
pilotage pour autant la Commission
considère qui n'est pas souhaitable de
rétablir cette charte d'engagement
qu'elle a supprimé je pense que pour en
signer des conventions etc mais qu'on
doit pas l'indiquer ici dans le projet
de loi j'ai bien vu quelques quelques
chartes y compris dans ma région mais
elles sont pas
précises et je pense que justement si on
a pu le signer avant le vote de du texte
de loi c'est que ce doit être possible
donc c'est un avis
défavorablement qui a reçu la vie
défavorable de leur rapporteur qui est
pour
qui contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté le 400 madame cancone je vous
vois oui c'est un amendement madame la
président qui est présenté par ma
collègue victoire jasmin qui souhaite
qu'il y ait un volet spécifique dans
cette gouvernance du réseau France
travail pour les collectivités régies
par les articles 73 et 74 de la
Constitution
quelle est la ville de la Commission
quand même la présidence ce sera un avis
défavorable comité national France
travail pourra définir des orientations
stratégiques en prévoyant des mesures
spécifiques pour les outre-mer sans
qu'ils soient besoin de l'écrire dans la
loi et ce seront les comités
territoriaux institués dans les
collectivités d'outre-mer qui seront les
plus à même d'adapter les actions en
faveur de l'emploi et de l'insertion aux
besoins locaux donc c'est un avis
défavorable
quelle est la vie du gouvernement mais
ma vie défavorable je mets aux voix
madame Cancun je vous donne la parole
pour une explication de vote amendement
retiré retirez merci trois amendements
merci madame la Présidente la commission
des affaires sociales a souhaité
inscrire au titre des attributions du
nouveau comité national l'identification
des besoins plus rien annuels de
financement pour les acteurs du réseau
France travail je comprends bien
évidemment la volonté de lisibilité et
de prévisibilité derrière cette
disposition cependant dire que le comité
national définit plutôt identifie les
besoins nous paraît préenter d'une
certaine manière les décisions et les
décisions autonomes souveraines de ceux
qui le composent l'état évidemment
puisque chaque année c'est la loi de
finance qui fixera les moyens mais aussi
les collectivités qui chaque année dans
leur propre budget décidons décideront
des moyens qu'elles allouent à la partie
à leur participation et aux actions de
France travail et donc nous craignons
que le fait de confier au Comité
National cette mission d'identification
et un caractère un peu prérompteur je ne
sais pas si ça n'est pas un néologisme
mais en tout cas de préemption sur les
décisions des membres du même comité
donc les auteurs de cet amendement
souhaitent que le comité national France
travaille et pour mission d'établir un
contrat d'engagement entre les
différents membres du réseau pour
s'accorder sur les besoins et objectifs
financiers ce projet de loi en effet
modifie profondément les rôles émissions
de nombreux acteurs inévitablement il y
aura des incidences financières et les
différents acteurs ont besoin de
lisibilité dans les moyens budgétaires
mobilisables d'où cette nécessité de
contractualiser les engagements
réciproques
merci madame la Présidente notre
amendement propose de remplacer à
l'alinéa 46 un certain nombre de petits
points et particulièrement supprimer le
droit de veto du ministre dans le Comité
National france-travail
supprimer les notifications des besoins
plus réels de financement pour réaliser
les actions le socle commun des services
au bénéfice des personnes et des
employeurs et établir les méthodologies
et référentiels importants
quelle est la vie de la Commission sur
ces trois amendements
même la présidence ce sera un avis
défavorable sur sur l'ensemble alors
l'amendement 619 supprime la mission qui
est confiée au Comité National France
travail d'identifier les besoins
financiers pluriels la commission
imprévue que l'État les collectivités
territoriales et les partenaires sociaux
qui siègeont dans le Comité National
France travail pourront identifier les
besoins pluriannuels de financement pour
la mise en oeuvre des missions
d'accompagnement il ne s'agit pas là de
fixer par avance le budget de l'État ou
des collectivités mais de confier au
comité une capacité de faire remonter
les éventuelles difficultés financières
constatées sur le terrain et d'alerter
sur les besoins pour mettre en oeuvre la
réforme cette prérogative donnera aux
acteurs davantage de visibilité pour
réaliser leurs actions c'est pourquoi
nous voulons la conserver donc mettons
un avis défavorable
l'amendement 380 prévoit les laboration
par le Comité National d'un contrat
d'engagement réciproque entre l'ensemble
des membres du réseau France travail
alors la commission a supprimé la charte
d'engagement je pense que on va pas
créer un contrat d'engagement réciproque
entre l'ensemble des membres ça crée un
cadre trop contraignant un parti en
particulier sur le plan financier donc
je crois qu'il faut laisser les membres
du comité national définir de manière
concertée les orientations et les outils
communs sont libres de les formaliser
ensuite dans une convention si il pense
que c'est nécessaire mais l'inscription
dans la loi je pense n'est pas utile
l'amendement 324 supprime l'approbation
par le ministre des indicateurs des
référentiels élaborés par le Comité
National France travail en fait pour
donner pour leur donner une valeur
juridique et qu'il soit appliquée
utilisée par les membres du réseau il
est pertinent de prévoir l'approbation
par le ministre des indicateurs et
référentiels élaborés par le Comité
National France travail pour autant ce
sera bien le com ité national l'état
collectivité partenaire sociaux qui
définira ses orientations et
référentielles et le ministre est en
chargé que de les approuver c'est un
avis défavorable sur votre amendement
ministre quel est votre avis sur les
deux autres amendements que le vôtre
merci madame la Présidente sur les deux
amendements celui de Monsieur Gillet de
Madame Ferré la vie défavorable pour les
mêmes raisons que celles évoquée par
madame le rapporteur l'amendement 619 du
gouvernement est maintenu j'ai entendu
la déclaration de madame le rapporteur
qui a je crois explicité la volonté de
la commission des affaires sociales de
ne pas présenter les décisions ni de
l'État ni des collectivités mais plutôt
d'identifier des besoins de les faire
remonter je pense que c'est utile pour
la suite des débats dans le cas de la
navette pour mieux comprendre
l'intention de la commission notamment
sur l'esprit de ces dispositions ceci
étant et pour les mêmes raisons que j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure et à titre
conservatoire si je veux dire
l'amendement est maintenu
donc voilà maintenant 619 du
gouvernement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission qui est
pour qui contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté le 380 double avis
défavorable qui est pour
qui contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté 324 même votes même vote le 53
monsieur canavet
il est défendu le 83
oui c'est un amendement qui vise en fait
à faire une une place bien inscrite au
niveau des
intercommunalités comme un acteur clé
donc des politiques de l'emploi de
l'insertion de la formation et de
l'orientation on sait que pour faire
face à ces enjeux il nous paraît
souhaitable que l'interco qui a quand
même une compétence en domaine soit
vraiment inscrite et précisé dans cet
article
310 madame Ferret
oui c'est le même amendement nous
souhaitons effectivement que la place
des intercommunalités soit bien prise en
compte dans l'émission du service public
de l'emploi quelle est la vie de la
Commission sur ces trois amendements
identiques
c'est une demande de retrait ou à des
fois un avis défavorable parce que les
amendements sont satisfaits dans la
mesure où il est prévu que seront
membres du réseau les régions les
départements et les communes et leur
groupement il n'est pas nécessaire
d'ajouter aux alinés à proposer que
seront aussi visées les groupements de
collectivités pour pouvoir inclure les
intercommunalités donc amendement
satisfait monsieur le ministre
merci Madame la présente à la première
lecture le gouvernement considérait que
l'amendement était satisfait mais en
réalité nous allons donner un avis
favorable ou de sagesse considérant que
derrière les groupements peuvent aussi
apparaître d'autres groupements que les
intercommunalités tels que définit de
manière classique et qui participent par
leur association leur travail leur
travail en coopération au service public
de l'emploi donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle la vie est favorable sur cet
amendement bien je vais donc mettre aux
voix
ces trois optiques madame la rapporteur
mais là c'est mon avis personnel si
vraiment vous pensez que il y a une
omission dans justement dans ces
groupements à ce moment-là
personnellement j'ai donné plusieurs
avis favorable parce qu'en fait nous on
veut pas exclure en fait
au niveau des collectivités donc voilà
donc avis personnel mais donc un avis
favorable je vais donc mettre au roi ces
trois amendements identiques madame
Gatel
merci madame la Présidente moi je suis
comment dire je comprends pas très bien
monsieur le ministre vous êtes un
lecteur attentif de tout et vous avez
profondément travaillé sur ce texte vous
l'avez dit et la rapporteur l'a dit ce
texte il est inclusif ce que on parle
bien des communes et de leurs
groupements donc naturellement
l'intercommunalité qui a la compétence
économique et dedans donc monsieur le
ministre sans vouloir aller chercher
midi à 14h je ne comprends pas pourquoi
soudainement vous nous dites que les
intercommunalités ne sont pas intégrées
alors quelles leçons j'ai vraiment je ne
comprends pas sauf à satisfaire à une
organisation particulière vraiment ça me
ça m'interpelle c'est insistance
merci madame la présidente madame la
présidente de la délégation a raison
d'une certaine manière j'ai manqué de
précision dans l'explication les
intercommunalités sont déjà dans le
réseau mais les intercommunalités nous
ont aussi signalés que notamment pour ce
qui concerne la capacité à réaliser des
Audi au sein des organismes délégataires
c'est à cet endroit que les
intercommunalités n'apparaissaient pas
donc on vient compléter le dispositif
avec ses amendes
je vais donc mettre voir ces trois
amendements identiques qui ont reçu un
double avis favorable de la rapporteur
et du ministre qui pour qui contre qui
s'abstient ils sont adoptés nous passons
à au 369 madame ponce
oui merci Madame présidente alors là il
s'agit quand même de de pallier à un
oubli regrettable je pense pour la
représentativité des employeurs la
présente rédaction du projet de loi
c'est à l'inclut les organisations
représentatives d'employeurs au niveau
interprofessionnel est-ce que de facto
les organisations représentatives au
niveau multi professionnel alors que les
entreprises de l'économie sociale et
solidaire agissent au quotidien en
faveur du service public de l'emploi et
ceci
ne pas inclure l'Union des employeurs de
l'économie sociale et solidaire est un
double défaut d'abord parce que il
représente quand même
2,3 millions de salariés 14 % de
l'emploi pris privé c'est une première
raison mais aussi parce que ce sont des
acteurs ces acteurs de l'économie
sociale et solidaire ils agissent
vraiment directement auprès des
opérateurs et partenaires du service
public de l'emploi comme l'émission
locale les organismes d'insertion les
entreprises adaptées les organismes de
formation pour répondre aux besoins des
demandeurs d'emploi et à la levée des
freins périphériques en ce qui concerne
le logement la garde d'enfants ou même
l'accompagnement à la mobilité compte
tenu de l'implication de l'économie
sociale et solidaire dont
l'accompagnement et l'insertion des
demandeurs d'emploi et de son poids
significatif si on est parlé dans le
tissu social il est indispensable que le
secteur puisse contribuer pleinement aux
décisions relatives aux enjeux nationaux
du service public de l'emploi et soit
dès lors représenté au sein du comité
national via son organisation
représentative multi-professionnelle à
savoir Ludes l'Union des employeurs de
l'économie sociale et solidaire cet
amendement propose donc de corriger cela
et d'inclure les organisations
représentatives au niveau national
interprofessionnel se dit mais
multiprofessionnels aussi au sein du
comité national et des comités
territoriaux France travail avant
d'assurer la représentativité des
employeurs de façon correcte notamment
par rapport à l'objet de ce projet de
loi
poursuivez madame pensez manger avec le
560 écoutez même la présidente mais
j'espère que voilà c'est un amendement
de
repli mais j'espère que le premier sera
c'est juste pour dire que c'est un peu
la même démonstration mais c'est pour
dire au moins que l'union des employeurs
de l'économie sociale et solidaire je
l'ai dit plus de 10% de l'emploi etc
soit à minima donc c'est bien de repli
représentée au niveau du Comité national
et donc le repli c'est d'enlever des
comités territoriaux France travail afin
d'assurer la représentativité voilà ça
me ferait vous présenter les trois
suivants
un amendement principal et de repli
apparemment
merci Benoît le président monsieur le
ministre effectivement par cet
amendement nous souhaitons donc des
acteurs de l'emploi puisse intégrer
cette nouvelle organisation qui est
proposée car compte tenu des enjeux
relatifs aux métiers en tension de
l'implication de ces adhérents dans
l'accompagnement à l'insertion des
demandeurs d'emploi et de son poids
significatif il est indispensable que
ludès l'union des employeurs de
l'économie sociale et solidaire puisse
contribuer pleinement aux décisions
relatives aux enjeux nationaux du
service public de l'emploi en effet
l'organisation du Comité National France
travail ne peut être pleinement
efficiente si elle écarte les
organisations d'employeur
représentatives au niveau national et
multi professionnel des organisations
patronales représentant des structures
agissant sur un pan entier de l'économie
nationale je rappelle que l'économie
sociale est solidaire qui regroupe
environ 200 000 entreprises qui
consignit activité économique et utilité
sociale et emploie plus de 2 millions de
salariés
14% de l'emploi privé l'économie sociale
et solidaire c'est une économie à part
mais une économie à part entière elle
participe également à répondre aux
besoins des demandeurs d'emploi en ce
qui concerne les sujets de logement de
garde d'enfants d'accompagnement à la
mobilité cela légitime d'autant plus le
représentation par le biais de Ludes au
sein du comité national et des comités
territoriaux de France travail
vous l'avez dit madame la présidente des
deux amendements suivants sont des
amendements de replis donc je ne
développerai pas puisque les choses ont
déjà été dites et vous avez compris le
sens de notre démarche dit Madame la
rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente alors ces
amendements entendent modifier les
critères permettant aux partenaires
sociaux de sujets au Comité National
France travail le texte prévoit
actuellement que siègeon au Comité
National les organisations d'employeurs
et de salariés
représentatives au niveau national et
professionnel c'est très majoritairement
ce niveau de représentativité qui est
retenu pour la concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux au niveau national
il est donc logique que ce critère soit
retenu par le Comité National France
travail dans lequel les partenaires
sociaux auront voient des libératives
avec l'État et les collectivités
territoriales c'est pourquoi nous sommes
réticents à donner les mêmes
prérogatives dans le comité aux
organisations d'employeurs
multiprofessionnels elles pourront
néanmoins toujours être associés aux
travaux des comités France travail et de
même nous ne souhaitons pas que des
organisations syndicales non
représentatives au niveau national et
les mêmes prérogatives que les
organisations
représentative quand elle leur présence
dans les comités territoriaux il est
déjà envisagé que les partenaires
sociaux seront représentés dans les
comités territoriaux en particulier dans
les comités régionaux puisqu'ils sont
déjà présents dans le créfop donc pour
autant la composition des comités
territoriaux sera précisé par décret
après concertation avec les acteurs
concernés vous donc pas l'affiger dans
la loi donc c'est un avis défavorable
sur l'ensemble de ces amendements
monsieur le ministre
c'est le même avis exactement pour les
mêmes raisons la question n'est pas
illégitime puisque derrière la question
de la représentation des organisations
multiprofessionnelles ou un certain
nombre d'organisations syndicales se
posent des questions de représentativité
et c'est un débat qui est souvent ouvert
qui n'a jamais été fermé depuis
longtemps mais qui est souvent ouvert
notamment sur les critères de
représentativité où cette différence
interpro multi pro et y compris les
critères qui passent qui permettent de
passer de l'un à l'autre par
construction le Gouvernement présente un
texte qui s'appuie sur les critères
classiques de représentativité
interprofessionnelle d'une part et de
représentativité syndicale au sens des
critères qui s'appliquent aujourd'hui
d'autre part donc la question n'est pas
illégitime il y aura certainement des
concertations nécessaires et même un
travail de peut-être un travail de
redéfinition sur ces sujets là mais en
l'état la vie est favorable
alors je vais donc
Madame renseignement je voulais un
explication de vote oui je pense que
c'est pas tout à fait clair de de
vouloir faire la collusion avec les
organisations syndicales ça aurait pu
être l'objet d'un amendement mais c'est
pas l'objet de l'amendement donc on
parle pas là on parle de la
représentativité et ils sont
représentatifs plus ils sont multiples
professionnels certes les cinq côtes
sont représentatifs depuis 1945 on
l'entend bien enfin comme les
organisations syndicales mais là ils
sont représentatifs ils sont
représentatifs de tout un pan de
l'économie et en plus un pan de
l'économie qui est complètement dans
l'objet dans l'esprit de cette loi donc
il s'agit pas de d'inclure quelqu'un qui
est pas représentatif et d'élargir le
concept ils sont représentatifs sont
multiples professionnels et je comprends
pas que on barre pour une fois que je
défends vraiment la représentativité de
de
d'un employeur mais là c'est vraiment
inepte bon je trouve de ne pas les
inclure ou non est-ce que ça n'a rien à
voir c'est pour ça que je conteste le
fait que on on on comment dire on fait
la confusion avec ce qu'on demanderait
que je sais pas les organisations
syndicales d'une ça Sud soit représentée
là on parle du collège employeur
merci à mon tour effectivement
d'insister sur l'importance de la
présence de l'udesse et sa
représentativité je rappelle ce sont 2,3
millions de salariés qui relèvent de ce
secteur 14 % de l'emploi privé donc
c'était pas de ou 3 salariés Ludes
également membre de différentes
instances de concertation nationale aux
côtés des autres partenaires sociaux
donc je vais vous épargner la liste qui
est relativement longue mais vous la
connaissez comme moi donc instance de
concertation nationale instance de
concertation européenne instance de
concertation régionale et départementale
donc voilà pourquoi nous insistons
j'insiste à mon tour pour que les dettes
soient parties prenante de cette
nouvelle organisation
alors sur ces deux amendements s'il n'y
a pas d'autres explications de vote sur
tous ces moments je suis d'abord saisi
d'une demande de scrutin public à
l'article pour l'amendement 369 à la
demande du groupe écologie solidarité de
territoire le scrutin est ouvert
personne ne demande à votre télé
votant 343 exprimer 340 pour 90 contre
250 le Sénat n'a pas l'adopté une autre
demande de scrutin public sur le 3
[Musique]
sur les 560 pardon sur le 560 ce qu'on
pourrait imaginer la même vote
et peut-on imaginer un même vote madame
ponce sur le
560 sur lequel vous avez fait aussi une
demande de scrutin public
même vote vous êtes d'accord donc il
n'est pas adopté
madame Ferrer le 311
excusez-moi je vous ai vu vous lever
j'étais alors le 311 même vote
le 439 même vote le 440 même vote ils ne
sont pas adoptés et nous passons à
l'article 4 la suite trois identiques
qui est là qui est là Monsieur monsieur
Maignan
déposé par notre collègue Müller Braun
nous dit que la gouvernance de France
travail prévoit la mise en place d'un
comité nationale au sein duquel ni les
usagers du service public de l'emploi ni
leurs associations ne sont représentées
il convient d'introduire au sein du
comité national une représentation des
usagers de France travail et de leurs
associations représentatives dont les
associations représentant les
travailleurs en situation de handicap
afin d'assurer une pleine participation
des personnes bénéficiaires au
dispositifs les concernant
merci
l'identique suivante et Madame le héros
oui il s'agit du même amendement donc
pour intégrer les usagers du service
public de l'emploi et leurs associations
dans la gouvernance de France travail
comme vous nous sommes très favorables à
une plus grande inclusion des personnes
en situation de handicap en milieu
ordinaire c'est une excellente chose
mais ça ne doit pas être le prétexte à
un accompagnement dégradé de ces
personnes qui ne pourront pour certaines
d'entre elles n'avoir une intégration
réussie sur le long terme que si elles
ont un soutien important et qui leur
sera nécessaire afin de veiller à
garantir cet accompagnement de qualité
et adapté cette participation des
usagers handicapés aux instances de
gouvernance est essentielles c'est
accompagnement spécialisé nécessite des
moyens adaptés aux besoins qu'ils seront
faire valoir auprès des instances de
gouvernance nationale
mais maman défendu se mouiller le 219
défendu madame a poursaut poli madame
gréaume
par cet abonnement nous souhaitons que
soit inscrit dans la loi la
représentativité des demandeurs d'emploi
en situation de handicap et des
associations qui les représentent au
sein de la gouvernance nationale de
France travail ce projet de loi a au
moins le mérite d'aborder la question
des travailleurs handicapés et de leur
accompagnement il est toutefois
nécessaire qu'elle et qu'il soit
représenté quand on pilotage de la
structure France travail les
travailleurs en situation de handicap
sont des travailleurs comme les autres
mais avec des besoins spécifiques il est
dès leur indispensables qui puisse faire
valoir ses besoins au sein de
l'organisme lui-même merci le 504 madame
ponce
merci madame la Présidente c'est
amendement a pour objet de compléter la
composition du comité national France
travail suivant ainsi des
recommandations du Conseil d'État qui
conseille de modifier le projet de loi
afin que les catégories de membres
composant le Comité National France
travail soit définie de manière
exhaustive nous regrettons ainsi
l'absence des demandeurs d'emploi en
situation de handicap des associations
représentatives de ces personnes dans la
gouvernance nationale de France travail
ainsi que l'absence des associations et
représentants d'usagers de Pôle emploi
et des représentants des structures
d'insertion alors même que ces
structures sont essentielles pour
établir des référentiels communs et des
critères d'orientation pertinents
éloignez l'ensemble de ces structures
d'un comité en charge de l'orientation
des politiques de l'emploi ne pourraient
aboutir qu'à diminuer grandement
l'efficacité du réseau France travail
dans sa capacité à accompagner
correctement il en diminue aussi
grandement l'acceptation démocratique
dès lors qu'il aura élaboré des
orientations stratégiques qui n'auront
que partiellement été discutées par
l'ensemble des structures et personnes
concernées or cette acceptation est
essentielle pour protéger les
conseillers qui subissent de plus en
plus d'agressions du fait de la violence
perçue des politiques mises en oeuvre
ces dernières années de
l'incompréhension devant les changements
et contrôle en fin de la difficulté du
service public de l'emploi est en mesure
de tenir compte des besoins des usagers
donc voilà c'est un rendement propose
ainsi que ces derniers est une voie dans
le Comité national et que ça soit défini
comme le propose le Conseil d'État de
manière exhaustive
[Musique]
merci madame la Présidente alors les
amendements 1362 207 482 ajoute dans le
Comité national des représentants des
usagers l'amendement 219 ajoute dans le
Comité national des représentants
d'usagers représentants d'entreprises
adaptées et des actes l'amendement 504
souhaite créer un au sein du comité
national un collège de représentation
d'associations de personnes en situation
de handicap alors le texte de la
Commission a déjà ajouté une mission
supplémentaire pour les membres du
réseau France travail ils devront
organiser la participation des usagers à
la définition et à l'évaluation de leurs
actions l'intention des amendements est
dans pleinement satisfaite et qu'on
viendra de laisser les acteurs choisir
les modalités d'association des usagers
et pour les ESAT et les Entreprises
Adaptées c'est aussi pleinement
satisfait donc demande de retrait ou un
avis défavorable sur l'ensemble de ces
amendements
merci Madame la présence c'est le même
avis la ligne à 28 de l'article tel
qu'il a été modifié par la commission
d'affaires sociales pour prendre en
compte la participation des usagers et
des bénéficiaires permet de couvrir
c'est différentes propositions Islam
permet par ailleurs de dire au banc bien
évidemment qu'à l'occasion des
différents actes réglementaires que le
gouvernement aura à prendre bien
évidemment la représentation des
associations représentant les esates les
EA et les personnes en situation de
handicap seront prises en compte pour
que la composition des comités soit
conforme à la volonté des auteurs
d'amendements satisfait par cette
disposition générique donc c'est une
demande de retrait ou à des freins de la
vie défavorable bien si ils sont
maintenus je vais donc les mettre au
bois monsieur
mouiller vous retirez monsieur Maignan
c'est un maintenant merci mais
Présidente c'est amendement vise à
garantir la présence des structures de
l'insertion par l'activité économique
actrice incontournable du plein emploi
solidaire au sein des instances de
gouvernance au niveau départemental et
au niveau local déployés dans le cadre
de France travail en effet la rédaction
actuelle du projet de loi ne précise pas
la place de ces structures dans le
schéma des gouvernances locales et
départementales de France travail pour
autant ces acteurs de l'insertion
agissent au plus près de là pour le coup
des personnes les plus éloignées de
l'emploi en proximité dans leur action
de repérage d'accompagnement et de
formation elles agissent sur les freins
dit périphériques pour favoriser l'accès
à l'emploi durable des personnes en
situation de précarité ils sont
également un maillon important du
développement économique territorial par
ailleurs les structures d'insertion par
l'activité économique sont actuellement
déjà réunies dans des instances locales
et départementales comme par exemple les
conseils départementaux d'insertion par
l'activité économique ce sont donc les
instances qui permettent de définir
collectivement en lien étroit avec les
services de l'État et les collectivités
territoriales la stratégie en matière
d'insertion par l'activité économique
ainsi s'il est CDI AE sont amenés à
disparaître dans la nouvelle
organisation de France travail il paraît
nécessaire du coup de les inclure
d'inclure ces structures d'insertion par
l'activité économique dans les nouvelles
instances de gouvernance et de les doter
d'une voix délibérative je vous remercie
la présidente alors c'est exactement le
même amendement que celui présenté par
Madame ponce et excellemment présenté
donc je ne je vais le dire défendu c'est
un amendement qui a été proposé et
travaillé avec la Fédération des acteurs
de solidarité et donc et d'autres
associations ces acteurs donc agissent
vraiment au plus près des personnes
les personnes les plus éloignées de
l'emploi et donc il serait opportun de
les intégrer dans la gouvernance locale
et la gouvernance départementale de
France travail madame la rapporteur
votre avis
oui mais la Présidente c'est un moment
est pleinement satisfait le texte de la
Commission prévoit déjà en fait que les
représentants déstructures d'insertion
réactivité économique siègeront au
Comité National France travail c'est
donc demande de retrait ou un avis
défavorable ministre même avis madame
pensée mange vous maintenez ou
vous maintenez double avis défavorable
qui est pour qui contre qui s'abstient
ils ne sont pas adoptés le 167
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre à l'instar de la composition
du conseil d'administration de Pôle
Emploi aujourd'hui ou les organisations
des salariés et les employeurs
représentatifs au niveau national
interprofessionnel dispose au total de
10 voix sur 19 le présent amendement
vise à assurer aux partenaires sociaux
un nombre de voix représentants au total
au moins la moitié au sein du comité
national France travail
[Musique]
oui bien alors ensuite le 225 madame
Gacquerre
défendu ok quelle est la ville d'un
rapporteur sur ses amendements
alors merci madame la Présidente alors
c'est un avis défavorable me semble pas
opportun de prévoir dans la loi que les
partenaires sociaux aient au moins la
moitié des voies délibératives alors que
la gouvernance nationale au sein du
comité France travail sera tripartite
entre avec l'État et les collectivités
territoriales je ne suis pas certaine
qu'ils soient pertinents que les
partenaires sociaux aient plus de voix
que l'État et les collectivités ces
modalités de délibération seront plutôt
à préciser par voie réglementaire et par
la concertation entre les différents
acteurs c'est donc un avis défavorable
c'est le même avis une demande de
retrait ou un avis défavorable puisqu'il
ne s'agit pas d'un conseil
d'administration qui gère un service
mais bien un comité national
d'orientation qui définit les
orientations prioritaires de la
politique de l'emploi orientation qui
sera ensuite mise en oeuvre par
l'opérateur donc on n'est pas dans un
conseil d'administration avec une
recherche de paritarisme madame le
rapporteur l'a dit il y a il ne serait
pas totalement logique de prévoir par
avance qu'il y a autant de voix que les
régions l'État les départements les
autres collectivités locales qui
participeront en tout premier lieu au
financement et à la mise en œuvre des
dispositions d'insertion ou de formation
donc retrait au défavorable
oui merci madame la Présidente à la
lumière des explications effectivement
il m'avait pas échappé que c'était de
porter réglementaire mais c'est
simplement pour préciser les
orientations à donner ensuite au
dispositions réglementaires ensuite
j'entends les arguments et je vous ai
pas de confusion avec un conseiller
d'administration c'est bien un comité
d'orientation simplement il me semblait
que par rapport à la situation actuelle
et à la représentation qu'avait les les
représentants salariés et patronaux au
sein de l'instance de Pôle emploi il me
semblait utile d'avoir cette précision
mais je me range aux arguments de Madame
rapporteur de Monsieur le Ministre et je
retire un amendement le 220 il est
retiré aussi
oui bien sûr madame gaker vous faites
quoi du veau de vous le retirez monsieur
le ministre votre amendement 622 et
après on fera une petite suspension
après l'amendement du Gouvernement
merci madame la Présidente c'est un
amendement qui vise à prévoir une forme
de corde de rappel puisque la commission
des affaires sociales a souhaité qu'un
certain nombre d'orientation soit défini
par la communauté nationale France
travail ce que nous partageons nous
avons par contre une forme de crainte
c'est le cas hypothétique ou le comité
n'arriverait à se mettre d'accord et à
formuler ses orientations et nous
proposons comme corde de rappel qu'en
cas de blocage de discussion le
gouvernement puisse prendre par arrêter
conjoint du milieu du travail du musée
solidarité les orientations nécessaires
pour avoir une forme de mécanisme
supplétif voilà l'objet d'amendement
madame la Présidente et puisque vous
avez dit à l'instant qu'après l'examen
de cette amendement vous feriez une
suspension de séance je saisis
l'occasion pour dire à mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs que je dois
gagner maintenant pour une réunion de
préparation du PLFSS et que madame
Carole Grandjean ministre délégué auprès
de moi me remplacera jusqu'à la pause
pour que personne ne soit surpris à la
reprise
merci quelle est la vie de leur
rapporteur sur cet amendement du
Gouvernement
alors merci madame la Présidente ce sera
un avis défavorable monsieur le ministre
c'est pas gentil je sais nous avons
modifié le texte en commission afin que
les critères d'orientation des
demandeurs d'emploi et les modalités
d'échange d'information sur ces critères
soit défini de manière concertée par le
Comité National France travail état
collectivité partenaires sociaux et
ensuite approuver par le ministre plutôt
qu'il soit fixé par arrêter ministériel
l'amendement conserve cette modification
de la commission mais prévoit que ces
critères pourront être fixés par arrêter
en l'absence de définition par le comité
ou d'approbation par le ministre alors
cette procédure revient à donner la main
au gouvernement s'il ne souhaite pas
approuver ce qu'a fixé le Comité
national et c'est ce que nous ne
souhaitons pas monsieur le ministre donc
avis défavorable je mets au vois cet
abandon du gouvernement qui a reçu un
avis défavorable de la commission qui
est pour
qui contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté je
suspends la séance pour 5 minutes
la soupe c'est reprise avec l'amendement
221 de madame gaker
madame la Présidente si la composition
des comités régionaux doit être agile
pour pouvoir associer tous les acteurs
idoine il convient néanmoins de préciser
la composition du noyau dur de ce comité
afin qu'aucune partie intéressée ne soit
oubliée ou tout particulièrement les
partenaires sociaux qui sont membres du
créfop du bureau du créfop les
représentants des partenaires sociaux
dans les territoires contribuent en tant
que bénéficiaire des services de Pôle
emploi et du futur réseau France travail
à aborder les problématiques de manière
globale et la présence des organisations
syndicales d'employeur au sein des
comités régionaux est indispensable pour
contribuer au retour à l'emploi des
citoyens car elles seuls sont en mesure
de représenter de porter la voix de
toutes les entreprises pardon quelle que
soit leur taille et leur secteur
d'activité qui participent à
l'attractivité économique sociale et
culturelle des territoires je vous
remercie et le deuxième
le deuxième s'il a donc le 163
c'est ça oui si la composition des
comités régionaux doit être fragile pour
pouvoir associer tous les c'est le même
en fait donc
merci Madame la rapporteur quel est
votre avis sur ces deux amendements
merci ma belle Présidente c'est un avis
défavorable il est déjà prévu que l'État
et la région seront représentés dans les
comités régionaux puisqu'ils seront
présidés par le préfet et le président
de région les partenaires sociaux
siègent au CREFOP qui chapotera le
comité régional pour le reste il n'est
pas opportun de lister dans la loi la
composition des comités territoriaux il
est déjà prévu qu'un décret précisera
cette composition il conviendra qu'il
soit pris après concertation et en outre
il faut laisser de la souplesse au
comité pour associer les membres les
plus pertinents selon l'organisation
territoriale donc défavorable ou retrait
même avis madame Yaker vous retirer
6 amendements
identiques on commence avec le
24 monsieur blanc
et ben
il est défendu madame Ferret
en dire en quelques mots la raison pour
laquelle nous proposons la suppression
de la Linéa 50 car cette proposition
dérogatoire contrevient totalement à la
compétence exclusive des régions en
matière de formation professionnelle
telle que cela est défini par le Code du
travail quelqu'un défendu
madame pour ces mots j'ose pas défendu
oui ben je suis désolé j'arrive juste
voilà
oui c'est sur la proposition de
dérogatoire qui est incluse dans cet
article qui contient oui c'est ce qui
vient de dire la compétence exclusive
des régions en matière de formation
professionnelle cette proposition
dérogatoire propose aux actuels très
fort d'adopter le nom comité régional
France travail une modification qui nous
semble inutile qui n'apporte rien de
plus aux compétences exercées par le
créfop et clairement établi par la loi
et qui pourrait par ailleurs à terme
contrevenir à la compétence exclusive
exclusive des régions en matière de
formation professionnelle laquelle est
d'importance dans l'accompagnement à
l'emploi donc voilà cet article nous
semble encombrer une loi déjà complexe
d'un ajout qui n'apporte aucune
plus-value réelle l'obsession à vouloir
renommer l'ensemble des comités des
services en France travail d'ailleurs
que peu de sens puisque les orientations
prises par la loi concernant l'emploi et
non le travail et que le CREFOP ou
commitaire régional exerce des
compétences en matière d'accès à la
formation et non directement sur le
travail en soi donc c'est aléinéa
n'apporte rien et n'ajoutant qu'une
compétence supplémentaire au crafope il
est proposé de la supprimer voilà madame
la rapporteur quel est votre avis sur
ces amendements
oui merci madame la Présidente c'est un
avis défavorable parce que c'est comment
dans la mesure où la possibilité de
donner au CREFOP de prendre le nom de
comité régional France travail sera
soumise à l'accord du préfet du
président de région je ne vois pas
pourquoi nous empêcherions les régions
qui souhaitent d'opter pour ce
changement de nom parce que c'est la
Linéa 50 c'est ça cette possibilité ne
modifiera en rien les compétences des
régions il s'agit simplement d'une
modalité d'organisation laissons chaque
région choisir entre le maintien de deux
entités ou la transformation du créfop
en comité régional France travail ce qui
sur le fond de modifiera pas ses
attributions avis défavorable madame la
ministre même avis je vois donc je mets
au vois ces amendements identiques qui
est pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
ils ne sont pas adoptés alors le 54
monsieur Châtillon monsieur Canevet
monsieur Cannet vous me paraissez
il est défendu d'accord monsieur
Guillaume
alors la loi maptam et la loi notre ont
toutes deux joué en rôle essentiel dans
la reconnaissance des compétences et
collectivités territoriales notamment
pour les métropoles grâce à leur
capacité à mettre en oeuvre des
politiques d'insertion et de formation
professionnelle à réunir les différents
acteurs du monde économique social de la
formation professionnelle à mobiliser
les ressources financières et à
favoriser l'aménagement du territoire
les métropoles sont des acteurs clés
pour relever le défi de l'emploi et de
la croissance démographique économique
aussi en cohérence avec les deux lois
que précitées qui leur confère un rôle
central dans le développement économique
et la promotion de l'emploi sur leur
territoire c'est amendement vise à ce
que les métropoles qu'au président les
comités locaux dans leur ressort
géographique
merci Madame poncer Monge pour
l'identique là 556 c'est je vous propose
dans la foulée de défendre le 552 oui
effectivement c'est de 556 comme il
vient d'être dit propose que une coupe
résidence de droits au métropole sur les
comités locaux dans leur ressort
géographique par ailleurs pour tenir
compte de la configuration actuelle des
espaces de gouvernance locaux il est
proposé la possibilité d'élargir le
découpage du bassin d'emploi au-delà du
périmètre de la métropole en accord bien
entendu avec les intercommunautés
internes
et les communes présentes sur ce
territoire
et vous m'avez dit 152 qui suit
une gouvernance déclinée de façon
territoriale au travers de quatre
comités donc ça c'est la loi nationale
régionale départementale et local la
métropole de Lyon est en pleinement
concernée par toutes les dispositions
législatives ce référent au département
en vertu de l'article L
3641-2 du Code Général des Collectivités
Territoriales il convient néanmoins de
s'assurer que le niveau départemental
entre guillemets qui est nommé mentionné
par le texte vise le département en tant
que collectivité et non la
circonscription administrative en effet
dans le second cas seul un comité France
travaille départemental serait créé au
niveau de la circonscription
administrative du Rhône englobant ainsi
le grand Lion mais aussi le département
nouveau Rhône donc c'est amendement
utile je pense vise à la création de
deux comités territoriaux distincts sur
le territoire de la circonscription
administrative du Rhône afin de doter
ces deux collectivités territoriales
d'un outil de gouvernance propre c'est
amendement a pour objectif de ne pas
déséquilibrer la politique
départementale du nouveau Rhône et des
228 communes non situées sur le
territoire de la métropole de Lyon et de
tenir compte donc de la configuration
particulière de cette dernière je vous
remercie alors quelle est la ville de la
Commission sur ses amendements
alors merci madame la Présidente ce sera
un avis défavorable la procédure prévue
pour créer des comités locaux off de la
souplesse définition du ressort
territorial pertinent par le préfet
après concertation avec les élus locaux
et sur proposition des comités régionaux
et départementaux et donc pas nécessaire
de préciser que les comités locaux sont
institués à l'échelon de la métropole
dans les collectivités à statut
particulier ce sera possible dans le
cadre proposé l'intention de
l'amendement des amendements du moins et
donc satisfaite
madame la ministre
merci madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs effectivement je voudrais
insister sur le fait que cette
disposition est satisfaite en premier
lieu parce que le projet de loi prévoit
d'ores et déjà trois niveaux de comité
France travail pour être donc au plus
près des territoires et s'adaptés aux
compétences respectives des de chaque
niveau de collectivité également parce
que le gouvernement a déposé un
amendement qui vise à préciser que les
comités
comprennent notamment des représentants
des communes et des intercommunalités
désignés par l'association
départementale représentant les communes
et intercommunalités et je voudrais
vraiment dire qu'en fonction des
contextes et des caractéristiques des
bassins d'emplois le choix du
co-président doit pouvoir être différent
pour permettre la différenciation en
fonction des contextes locaux je vous
remercie un avis défavorable car
satisfait bien je vais donc mettre au
voie d'abord les trois amendements
identiques double avis défavorables qui
est pour
vous retirez mais il en reste
donc les amendements sans au lieu de
Monsieur canevecchi pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient ils ne sont pas adoptés
le 552 même vote même vote il n'est pas
adopté ensuite le monsieur blanc vous
défendez le 29 apparemment merci madame
la Présidente la représentation de la
région et dans chaque comité
départemental de France travail va
permettre de proposer des parcours sans
couture d'insertion jusqu'à l'emploi aux
personnes qui en sont le plus éloignées
et en particulier les bénéficiaires du
RSA
région et départements travaillent déjà
au quotidien pour articuler leur
compétences par le biais soit de
conventionnement de réunion régulière ou
encore dans le cadre du service public
de l'insertion et de l'emploi le spi
caric 73 de cet article prévoit d'ouvrir
les comités régionaux de l'emploi de la
formation et de l'orientation
professionnelle les greffes aux
représentants des départements alors par
analogie par souci d'équilibre la
représentation des régions au sein des
comités départementaux de France travail
doit être prévu
merci Madame Guillotin
madame Ferret
il a été très bien présenté pour tous
les mêmes arguments et donc il est
défendu
alors quelle est la vie de la Commission
n'en profitez pas
merci merci Madame la madame la
Présidente alors malheureusement ça va
être un avis défavorable donc comme je
l'ai dit me semble pas opportuns figée
dans la loi à la composition des comités
territoriaux je crois qu'on parle de
souplesse de liberté et finalement on
rajoute des contraintes à chaque fois en
l'espèce si l'on prévoit que des
représentants de la région siège dans
chaque comité départementale mais alors
pourquoi vous ne prévoyez pas que des
représentants des départements siègent
dans les comités régionaux exercice qui
consisterait à tout préciser de la sorte
dans la loi est un peu risquée nous
allons oublier certains membres alors il
préférable que les compositions des
comités résulte de concertation avec les
acteurs concernés donc je rappelle avis
défavorable sur l'ensemble de ses
amendements madame la ministre même avis
je mets aux voix double avis défavorable
qui est pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient ils ne sont pas adoptés alors
on commence avec le 506 de Madame
poncetmanche sur une très en discussion
commune
oui merci la présidence alors que la
composition des comités nationaux et
listés au sein du projet de loi la
composition les modalités d'organisation
et de fonctionnement des comités
territoriaux France travail sont
renvoyés à un décret donc c'est le flou
faut faire confiance paraît-il sans que
l'on soit assuré de la participation des
partenaires sociaux des usagers de Pôle
emploi et des structures d'insertion à
tous les échelons de la mise en oeuvre
du service public de l'emploi la
participation des partenaires sociaux et
crucial pour le bon fonctionnement du
service et la protection des droits des
salariés au moment même où les
portefeuilles des conseillers de Pôle
Emploi on l'a dit sont surchargés et par
le biais de l'inscription obligatoire
des allocataires du RSA on veut question
est encore plus chargée dégradant très
probablement leurs conditions de travail
déjà extrêmement difficiles en
conséquence
je les signalé la mission flash Pôle
Emploi
donne pourtant essentiel passe enfin dit
que un demandeur d'emploi sur inscrit en
modalités renforcée n'a pas eu
d'entretien avec son conseiller référent
5 mois après son inscription ça c'est la
réalité l'amélioration de
l'accompagnement des demandeurs d'emploi
passe par l'amélioration des conditions
de travail aussi des conseillers donc
quand on difficulté à léguer à trouver
des syndicats des associations ou des
représentants des usagers le pays
comprend 6 millions de chômeurs chargent
à l'état de favoriser le développement
des associations de défense des usagers
afin de leur permettre de poursuivre
leur mission d'utilité publique
merci vous pouvez enchaîner sur 507
madame ponce
oui
le 607 là ça propose d'intégrer les
partenaires sociaux au sein des comités
territoriaux France travail car
effectivement ils sont prévus en
National ils sont mais ils sont pas et
en régional mais ils sont pas prévus en
deçà
on a un projet de loi qui substitue une
vingtaine de comités de pilotage par
quatre comités territoriaux dont au
moins deux sont exemples d'un
participation de certains des acteurs
les plus importants du dialogue social
et de la mise en œuvre des actions du
service public de l'emploi
nous ne comprenons pas nous les
difficultés à léguer par Monsieur le
Ministre a trouvé des syndicats par
exemple la CGT est doté de 97 unions
départementales parce que c'est les
difficultés c'est ce qui nous a été dit
en commission d'affaires sociales mais
la CGTL est dotée de 97 unions
départementales et d'ailleurs le CFDT la
CGT lafo ont toutes des unions
territoriales interprofessionnelles au
niveau départemental donc pas de
difficultés la CGT elle a 803 union
locale donc vous voyez cela prouve s'il
le fallait la capacité d'un syndicat
représentatif est présent à tous les
échelons
et puis
comme monsieur le ministre avait doutait
de la capacité j'en profite pour lui
dire que dans son
dans son département l'Ardèche la CFDT à
5 unions locales sur le département de
l'Ardèche la CGT en A7
info on a quatre donc Privat
Tournon-sur-Rhône au Bénin Aubenas
Annonay La Voulte-sur-Rhône Le Cheylard
le tel donc vous voyez pas de difficulté
pour avoir au niveau départemental et un
fera départemental la représentation
qu'il y a au niveau national et régional
importante des partenaires sociaux merci
et le 314
par cet amendement nous proposons
d'insérer un alinéa supplémentaire
l'article 4 car en effet le projet de
loi ne prévoit rien sur la composition
des instances départementales et locales
de France travail et afin qu'aucune
partie intéressée nous soit oubliée il
se répertisant de caler cette
composition sur celle du CREFOP c'est ce
que propose cet amendement qui reprend
un article du code du travail le 223
madame guidez par exemple
défendu
le 315 madame Ferré
c'est le même sauf que là nous plaçons
cette proposition après la Linéa 52
défendu merci le 224 madame guidez
monsieur Longeot il est défendu
si le 140 monsieur Chassin est-il
défendu ou défendable
défendu très bien
le 153 monsieur gueule a l'air d'être
parti pour le défendre
l'objectif de plein emploi de bénéficier
à tous ceux qui rencontrent des
difficultés particulières pour accéder
au marché du travail notamment personne
handicapées malgré les efforts déployés
pour promouvoir leur inclusion dans le
marché du travail le taux de chômage des
personnes handicapées reste généralement
plus élevés que ceux de la population
générale favoriser leur inclusion sur le
marché du travail contribue à leur
émancipation à leur autonomie et surtout
à la construction d'une société plus
juste et équitable dans cet esprit c'est
que notre amendement propose que les
représentants d'usagés en situation de
handicap puisse être présent au sein des
instances de décision de France travail
le voilà ainsi défendu merci
au 123 monsieur Chassin défendu non
il a été défendu à cet instant par
Monsieur diol le 94 monsieur gueule
défendu
le 322 madame Ferret
merci donc sur cet amendement nous
rappelons que les entreprises adaptées
qui sont définies comme contribuant si
on définit par nous comme contribuant au
développement des territoires ces
entreprises sont des composantes
essentiels des politiques publiques du
handicap elle tente à développer
notamment par le biais d'expérimentation
l'accompagnement des transitions
professionnelles des personnes en
situation de handicap et leur mobilité
vers d'autres entreprises elle constitue
également un vivier de ressources
humaines et de compétences au service
des métiers en tension
afin de faciliter l'emploi et
l'insertion des travailleurs handicapés
la présence des représentants des
entreprises adaptées au sein de France
travail permettrait une meilleure prise
en compte des spécificités afférentes
cette amendement vise donc à ce que ces
entreprises sont représentées au sein
des comités territoriaux
le 480 je vous propose d'enchaîner sur
le 479 défendez les deux si vous le
voulez bien je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec vous Madame la Présidente on
enchaîne alors cet amendement le 479
au 480 c'est amendement donc visa
permettent aux entreprises adaptées de
constituer des instances de gouvernance
territoriales de France travail afin de
faciliter l'emploi et l'insertion donc
des travailleurs handicapés la présence
des représentants des entreprises
adaptées au sein de France travail
permettrait une meilleure prise en
compte des spécificités afférentes et
pour le 479 cette allemande vise à
s'assurer de la présence des
organisations syndicales dans les
comités territoriaux de France travail
je vous remercie moi et Madame la
rapporteur nous sollicitons notre avis
oui merci madame la Présidente alors
tous ces amendements souhaitent préciser
la composition des comités territoriaux
le nombre d'amendements qui apporte des
précisions à des degrés divers montre
bien la difficulté de l'exercice et le
risque de lister dans la loi tous les
membres des comités et certains
d'ailleurs sont absolument satisfaits
c'est pourquoi la Commission pense qu'il
n'est pas opportun de figer dans la loi
la composition des comités territoriaux
il est déjà prévu que les comités seront
présidées par le préfet et le président
de l'exécutif local ensuite un décret
devoir préciser la composition des
comités faudra qu'il soit pris en
concertation avec les représentants des
acteurs locaux et que chaque comité
dispose ensuite de marge de manœuvre
pour adapter la composition en réalité
des territoires et des bassins d'emplois
certains départements ont un réseau de
structures d'insertion plus ou moins
développés certains comptent de grandes
métropoles d'autres sont des territoires
ruraux etc donc la Commission ne
souhaite vraiment pas que la loi dresse
la liste des membres des comités
territoriaux c'est un avis défavorable
sur l'ensemble de ses amendements dans
la ministre même avis je vois alors je
vais donc mettre au voie on commence par
le 506 double avis défavorable qui est
pour
même vote le 314 même vote même vote le
223 qui est pour
qui contre qui s'abstient pas adopter
224 même votes pas j'en ai sauté
le 315
même vote
le 224 même vote pas adopté non plus le
140 même vote
le 153 même votes
le 123 même vote
et les trois identiques 94
322 480 même votes ils ne sont pas
adoptés le 479 enfin même vote même
votre aucun de ses amendement n'a été
adopté le 601 madame la ministre
merci madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs et sénateurs
écoutez voilà je souhaite chercher à
vous convaincre de nous suivre sur cet
amendement de rétablissement qui
d'ailleurs prend en compte les travaux
de la commission des affaires sociales
qui appelait à ce que les comités
départementaux et régionaux puissent
faire valoir leur propositions donc le
gouvernement souhaite absolument
accompagner cette volonté de la
commission des affaires sociales mais ne
souhaite pas conditionner l'existence
d'un comité local à la proposition des
comités régionaux et départementaux ils
ne souhaitent pas instaurer en fait de
facto une forme de hiérarchie des uns
par rapport aux autres et souhaite
éviter les blocages qui pourraient
subvenir survenir en cas de désaccord
toutefois voilà on entend les
propositions faites par la commission
des affaires sociales et donc on entend
l'intérêt des propositions qui pourront
être portées selon les territoires et
les contextes par le comité régional ou
le Comité Départemental auprès du préfet
de région et ce afin d'assurer une
cohérence dans la prise en compte des
spécialités locales c'est donc le sens
de cet amendement que nous vous appelons
à voter favorablement
du gouvernement
merci madame la Présidente même la
ministre je suis désolée ce sera
défavorable
la commission elle est souhaitée que les
comités locaux sont institués par le
préfet de département sur proposition
des comités régionaux ou locaux nous ne
souhaitons pas revenir au texte initial
qui donnait cette prérogative au préfet
de région
convient que ce soit le représentant de
l'État de proximité interlocuteurs
privilégié des élus qui disposent de
cette prérogative sincèrement le préfet
de région dans le département
partent dans le département en fait la
préfecture de région on voit pas
beaucoup en outre il est préférable que
ces décisions soient prises sur
proposition des comités régionaux et
territoriaux plutôt que de préciser que
le préfet pourra simplement prendre en
compte leur proposition donc avec
défavorable
madame Cancun
alors vous aviez levé votre main vous
vouliez des
très bien je mes envoie cet amendement
du gouvernement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission qui est
pour qui contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté alors le 58 monsieur Longeot
oui merci madame la Présidente c'est un
moment visa assuré que les présidents
des intercommunalités sont associés à la
définition des périmètres périmètre
défini pour instituer des comités
territoriaux locaux de france-travail
car ils sont les plus fin connaisseurs
connaissent à la fois des publics et
mais également des entreprises de leur
territoire cet amendement propose qui
est président des intercommunalités
puissent même être à l'initiative de ces
découpages s'il le souhaite je vous
remercie
madame la Présidente ce sera un avis
défavorable la Commission a déjà prévue
que les comités locaux seront instituées
sur proposition des comités régionaux
départementaux qui de manière concertée
avec les communes et les EPCI pourront
déjà évaluer l'opportunité de créer des
comités au niveau local selon les
bassins d'emploi donc l'intention me
semble satisfaite chers collègues
bien vu les explications rapporteur je
retire
par cet amendement nous souhaitons
comment dire modifier et compléter donc
la Linéa 54 en effet le projet de loi
positionne Pôle emploi à la fois en tant
qu'opérateur et dans la gouvernance du
réseau l'opérateur pour nous ne doit pas
faire partie de la gouvernance il doit
mettre en oeuvre sur la base des
priorités arrêtés par les instances de
gouvernance c'est donc la clarification
qui est ainsi proposée par le présent
amendement le 107 n'est pas défendu
monsieur gu
illaume la vie de la Commission
madame madame la Présidente sera un avis
défavorable alors sur le 3016 le Comité
national est à collectivité partenaire
sociaux définira les orientations
stratégiques et des référentiels qui
devront être suivies par Pôle emploi en
tant qu'opérateur toutefois il me paraît
inappropriée que les comités locaux
pilote les missions de Pôle emploi
qui est un établissement public national
avec des antennes locales sous tutelles
de l'État donc c'est un avis défavorable
sur le 316 et sur les 107 et 346 les
orientations stratégiques qui sont
définies par l'État les collectivités
les partenaires sociaux ont vocation à
poser des principes généraux pour la
coordination des acteurs et logique que
les comités territoriaux coordonnent
leur mise en oeuvre pour déployer la
politique de l'emploi sur le territoire
ces lignes directrices ne feront pas
obstacles au déploiement d'initiatives
locales et d'adaptation territoriale il
me semble donc pas nécessaire d'apporter
la modification qui est proposée ici
donc c'est défavorable sur les trois
amendements
mais ma vie
je mets aux voix d'abord le 316 qui est
pour qui contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté le 346 même votes même vote
il n'est pas adopté et nous passons
maintenant monsieur blanc vous commencez
avec le 26
oui merci et Madame les conférences des
financeurs sont redondantes avec les
comités territoriaux France travail et
ils n'ont donc pas lieu d'être à partir
du moment où chaque collectivité va
exercer et sa compétence donc c'est une
véritable simplification et c'est une
véritable clarification que de supprimer
cet alinéa 58 merci Madame Ferret
défendu monsieur Canevet oui c'était une
mesure de simplification
oui c'est un moment du groupe écologiste
a pour objet la suppression de la Linéa
introduisant le pilotage par les
résultats dont la logique et la
politique du chiffre risque de générer
tant un effet d'exclusion sociale des
publics les plus en difficulté que de
tri en laissant aux opérateurs publics
ou spécialisés les situations les plus
complexes alors que la loi ignore la
nécessité de considérer la qualité des
offres d'emploi et que rien n'est exigé
des employeurs quant à leur employeur
habilité puisque c'est pour le moment on
demandeur d'emploi simplement de
s'adapter aux emplois proposés le
pilotage par les résultats et le
renforcement des sanctions pousseront à
une dégradation de la qualité du retour
à l'emploi avec un risque d'aller-retour
précarisant davantage les populations en
grande difficulté et qui est dès à
présent d'ailleurs
évident de manière générale le pilotage
par les résultats conduit les acteurs
privés à privilégier un public plus
facile à accompagné vers l'emploi
pour le 27
le 318 madame Ferret
idem et enfin je crois que c'est
Monsieur canetv pour le dernier défendu
avant de repli également quelle est la
ville de la Commission sur ses
amendements
ça va tellement vite merci madame la
Présidente non non absolument pas
alors ce sera un avis défavorable pour
déployer des initiatives locales
adaptées aux besoins et des personnes et
des employeurs il sera utile pour les
comités territoriaux de réunir des
conférences de financeurs pour
l'insertion sociale et professionnelle
afin d'identifier les ressources
mobilisables dans le respect des
compétences de chaque financeur donc
c'est un invité favorable sur les
identiques 26317 337 501 et la mission
confiée au comité territoriaux de réunir
des conférences de financeurs ne
trouvera s'appliquer que si cela est
nécessaire et que le comité le juge
opportun pour déployer les actions sur
le territoire donc l'ajout de le cas
échéant ne semble sincèrement pas utile
donc c'est un avis défavorable aussi sur
le 27 318 et 338 madame la ministre mais
ma vie
très bien je vais donc mettre au voie
d'abord les quatre identiques qui est
pour
toute la vie défavorable qui est pour
alors on recommence 1 2 3 4 5
qui est contre
qui absinthe ne sont pas adoptés les
suivants même votes
même votre pas adopté ensuite madame
ponce aux 557
merci madame la Présidente alors depuis
de nombreuses années les métropoles ont
déployé de nombreux outils en lien avec
leurs compétences à titre d'exemple sur
le territoire de Grenoble Alpes
Métropole plus de 3500 personnes sont
accompagnées tous les ans par le pli est
constitué un acteur clé dans le
déploiement du service aux entreprises
notamment des TPE PME et des poids des
stratégies de partenariat avec les
universités et les acteurs de la
formation continue au vu de leur poids
économique et de leurs compétences en
matière de développement économique
ainsi serait peu efficient de ne pas
prévoir leur représentation de fait et
de droit au sein des comités régionaux
et départementaux de France travail dont
les compétences en matière de formation
et d'insertion peuvent être grandement
renforcés par la participation des
métropoles en leur sein il s'agit aussi
d'une proposition visant à garantir la
bonne coopération des différentes
instances et la complémentarité des
actions entreprises de part et d'autre
afin qu'aucune concurrence ou
chevauchement de dispositif ne
s'installe ainsi en vue de garantir la
complémentarité la cohérence des
interventions cet amendement vise
inclure les métropoles aux instances
départementales et régionales
il 55 monsieur Canevet
défendu le 88 monsieur Guillaume elle
vide la commission sur ces deux
amendements enfin trois dont deux avis
oui merci madame la Présidente
c'est dans la lignée de ce que j'ai
défendu président donc
nous avons donné les raisons et n'est
pas souhaitable de préciser dans la loi
la composition des comités territoriaux
voilà donc avis défavorable pour tous
ministre même avis alors je mets aux
voix d'abord le 557 qui est pour
qui contre qui s'abstiennent n'est pas
adopté monsieur Canevet vous retirez
monsieur gueule Vous retirez ok on passe
au 30 monsieur blanc
oui merci madame la Présidente la
commission des affaires sociales
a adopter un amendement qui prévoit que
la coupe résidence des comités locaux de
France travail est assuré conjointement
par le représentant de l'État
et un ou plusieurs représentants de
collectivités territoriales ou le
groupement de collectivités qui sont
désignés par l'association
départementale représentant les communes
et intercommunalités du département
en maintenant cette disposition
cet amendement prévoit conformément à la
proposition du rapport de la mission de
préfiguration France travail d'avril
2023 on est en page 205 que les comités
locaux France travail peuvent également
être coprésidés par le préfet de région
et le président du conseil régional
l'articulation entre le niveau local et
l'échelon régional est essentiel pour
gagner la bataille du pleine emploi
c'est ce que démontre au quotidien les
instances qui sont constituées par les
régions telles que klefop en Pays de
Loire Codev en centre Val de Loire les
CATF en Normandie la mobilisation pour
l'emploi en Grand Est ou encore spell en
haut de France d'ailleurs un comité
local France travail sous coprésident et
ta région est déjà expérimenté depuis
2023 dans les hauts de France dans le
cadre d'un protocole de préfiguration
qui avait été signé le 8 juin par l'État
et la région
en Pays de Loire le protocole de
préfiguration qui fut signé le 1er juin
dernier prévoit de simplifier et de
rendre plus efficace la gouvernance
publique du champ Emploi Formation
orientation insertion en s'appuyant sur
les instances de gouvernance en place en
particulier le créfop et j'ai
déclinaisons territoriale la possibilité
d'organisation à la carte en fonction
des caractéristiques de chaque
territoire permettra de garantir la
capacité d'adaptation aux enjeux
économiques et sociaux propres à chaque
bassin d'emploi et c'est en prévoyant
des mécanismes souples et diversifiés
que des solutions pour lever les freins
vers l'emploi seront trouvés
dans
oui je vais quand même prendre la parole
mais très rapidement donc c'est un
amendement effectivement c'est le même
qui reprennent préconisation du rapport
de la mission de préfiguration France
travail d'avril 2023 et qui prévoit que
les comités locaux puissent avoir une
co-présidence est à région alors cet
articulation entre le niveau local et
l'échelon régional me paraît à la fois
efficace et indispensable pour remporter
la bataille du plein emploi et je
citerai juste la mobilisation pour
l'emploi en grand est que je connais
bien je dirais même la remarquable
mobilisation en grandes s conçue par la
dretz en partenariat avec le Conseil
régional et Pôle emploi qui a montré à
la fois son efficacité et son dynamisme
monsieur Canevet défendu
merci Monsieur Madame Ferrer le 321
monsieur blanc le 25
oui merci madame la Présidente la
commission des affaires sociales avait
adopté un amendement qui prévoyait que
la coprésidence des comités locaux de
France travail était assuré
conjointement par le représentant de
l'État et un ou plusieurs représentants
de collectivités territoriales ou le
groupement de collectivités qui sont
désignés par l'association
départementale qui représente les
communes et les intercommunalités du
département
ce faisant cela empêche le président du
conseil régional de pouvoir co présider
ces comités pourtant il est essentiel de
remettre les régions au centre de la
gouvernance de ces comités et ce pour
plusieurs raisons en premier lieu le
rappeur de la mission de préfiguration
France travail
d'avril 2023 pardon avait expressément
prévu que les comités locaux France
travail puis cette coprésidée par le
préfet de région et le président du
conseil régional
l'articulation entre le niveau local et
l'échelon régional est primordial en
deuxième lieu et c'est ce que démontre
au quotidien les instances constituées
par les régions que les PhoP en Pays de
Loire code en Val de Loire ce que j'ai
indiqué tout à l'heure
et que c'est cette coprésidence est
parfaitement utile au projet et qui sont
menés d'ailleurs un comité local France
travail sous coprésident s'est ta région
est expérimenté en haute France en Pays
de Loire le protocole de préfiguration
signé le premier juin prévoit de
simplifier de rendre plus efficace la
gouvernance publique du champ Emploi
Formation parallèlement et dans un souci
de souplesse cet amendement prévoit que
le président du conseil régional pourra
après concertation des membres du comité
local décidé de déléguer la
co-présidence du comité à un maire à un
président établissement public de
coopération intercommunale c'est une
possibilité d'organisation à la carte
qui permet d'adapter les dispositifs au
bassin d'emploi et je crois que son
adoption serait particulièrement
bienvenue
le
108 n'est pas défendu et nous avons
ensuite monsieur Guillaume pour le 347
il est défendu madame la ministre
là il faut que vous le défendre
madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
concernant les comités locaux
l'intention du gouvernement a toujours
été de laisser la place à l'expression
de l'ensemble des collectivités
territoriales pour faire des
propositions au préfet de région et de
laisser ouvertes toutes les options
d'organisation pour tenir compte des
contextes locaux pour la désignation des
co-présidents des comités locaux il
s'agit très clairement de permettre à
une ou plusieurs collectivités
territoriales désignées par le préfet de
région à préavis des collectivités
membres du comité local de co-présider
ce comité c'est pourquoi le gouvernement
souhaite rétablir les dispositions
initiales du projet de loi qui laissent
une large place aux collectivité pour
définir la collectivité ou les
collectivités qui seront les plus
pertinentes dans la co-présidence au
regard des enjeux du territoire
sur un bassin d'emplois il peut en effet
être pertinent d'avoir une coprésidence
qui puisse par exemple revenir à la
région si un grand projet d'implantation
d'usine peut émerger alors que sur un
autre bassin ce serait plutôt le
département qui pourrait être la
collectivité pilote s'il s'agit de
mettre en place un plan d'action en lien
avec des personnes qui rencontrent de
grandes difficultés sociales dans un
autre ça pourrait être une co-présidente
d'une EPCI qui pourrait répondre donc à
un contexte local notamment s'il existe
une agence de développement local et
qu'une nouvelle zone d'activité est
implantée sur le bassin d'emploi s'il
faut reconvertir une zone ou s'il s'agit
de redynamiser par exemple un
centre-ville c'est the PCI ont une
proximité avec les entreprises du
territoire quelques soit la taille donc
en fonction des contextes et des
caractéristiques des bassins d'emplois
le choix dû ou des coprésidents doit
pouvoir donc être différent pour
permettre cette différenciation selon
les contextes locaux il ne s'agit
évidemment pas de méconnaître le rôle
des communes ou de leur groupement sur
les territoires mais d'accompagner de
réaffirmer l'intérêt de la présence des
communes et des groupements à tous les
échelons territoriales une
représentation aussi qui doit être
garantie par les associations d'élus
représentatives c'est le sens donc du
présent amendement
merci merci madame la Présidente alors
sur les amendements 30 193 341 321 25 et
340 ces amendements proposent que le
président de la Région qu'au président
le comité local certains en font une
faculté et d'autres une obligation le
texte prévoit que le comité local sera
co-prisé par un ou plusieurs
représentants de collectivités sera donc
possible que ce soit un élu régional ou
pas pour autant prévoir dans la loi que
ces comités soient co-présidés
obligatoirement par le président de
Région de manière obligatoire aux
prioritaire n'est pas pertinent ces
comité de niveau infra départemental
auront plutôt vocation à réunir en
premier lieu les élus des collectivités
du ressort du comité à savoir les
communes du bassin d'emploi les EPCI et
le président de Région de région pardon
qu'au président le comité régional
France travail
donc avis défavorable sur l'amendement
347 cet amendement propose le comité que
le comité local soit co-présidé par des
représentants des EPCI désignés par le
préfet là encore ce sera possible
puisque le texte prévoit que le comité
local sera qu'au président
de collectivités ou de groupements de
collectivités pour autant il ne faut pas
se limiter aux EPCI et par ailleurs la
Commission a préféré que les
coprésidents soient désignés par les
associations d'élus et non par le préfet
donc c'est un avis défavorable et sur
l'amendement 618 du gouvernement ce sera
aussi un avis défavorable madame la
ministre la Commission a fait le choix
que les coprésidents des comités locaux
qui représenteront les collectivités
soit désignées par les associations
d'élus communaux cela nous semble
préférable et plus adapté qu'une
désignation par le préfet de région
ensuite cet amendement prévoit que des
représentants des communes
intercommunalité soit membre des comités
territoriaux donc régional départemental
local et j'ai déjà indiqué plusieurs
fois que la Commission ne souhaitait pas
préciser dans la loi la composition des
comités de territoriaux donc défavorable
voilà madame la Présidente du
gouvernement
madame la ministre est-ce que vous
pourriez prendre le micro quand même
un avis défavorable sur les amendements
30 133 et
suivant et un ami évidemment favorable
sur l'amendement du Gouvernement bien je
vais donc mettre aux voix ces
amendements qui ont tous reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement sauve bien entendu la maman
du gouvernement
309341 qui est pour
le 321
qui est pour contre qui s'abstient pas
adopté le 347 même vote
le 25
340 même vote
pas adopté le 618 même monsieur du
gouvernement je mets aux voix qui est
pour qui contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté nous passons aux deux
rectifier terre qui va le défendre et
bien allez-y madame Estrosi ça sonne à
Nice merci madame la Présidente alors je
présente cet amendement au nom de ma
collègue Agnès canadien qui est donc
président d'une mission locale mais
comme le sont d'ailleurs d'autres
cosignataires de cet amendement je pense
plus particulièrement à ma collègue
Martha de Sidrac ou à moi-même puisque
nous sommes toutes deux également
présidente de mission locale le rapport
de la mission de préfiguration de France
travail proposé que les missions locales
coélaborent les orientations
stratégiques et co-animes des travaux de
France travail concernant les jeunes aux
côtés de l'opérateur France travail
aujourd'hui en l'état le texte ne
traduit pas cette volonté nous sommes
donc convaincus que pour réussir dans
l'insertion France travail a besoin du
réseau d'émissions locales comme le
propose l'Union nationale des missions
locales
il faut penser le réseau des missions
locales et ses partenaires comme le pôle
de prévention dans le réseau France
travail présidente de la Mission Locale
Miss Côte d'Azur je mesure les 40 années
d'expérience de ce service public
territorialisé dans un fonctionnement
partenariat dans l'insertion des jeunes
les missions locales sont de véritables
modèles de décentralisation du service
public de l'emploi et de l'insertion le
gouvernement a d'ailleurs
considérablement conforter leurs moyens
et amplifier les missions je pense plus
particulièrement à un jeune une solution
ou encore le contrat d'engagement jeune
elles ont depuis leur création développé
une méthode d'approche globale de
l'accompagnement des jeunes que France
travaille promeut et entend étendre à
d'autres publics elles sont activement
mobilisées auprès de l'ensemble des
employeurs locaux pour susciter des
vocations et les accompagner sur leurs
enjeux de recrutement aussi le réseau
des missions locales doit pouvoir mettre
son expertise de l'accompagnement des
jeunes au service des membres du réseau
France travail pour contribuer à
répondre au double défi de
l'amélioration de la situation des
jeunes dans tous les domaines et de la
recherche du plein emploi il s'agit
également de reconnaître l'engagement
des élus qui se mobilisent dans la
gouvernement des Miss dans la
gouvernance des missions locales et de
leur confier un rôle adapté pour qu'il
puisse continuer à œuvrer pour l'intérêt
général au sein du futur réseau France
travail merci Madame pour ce petit le
497 non monsieur Laennec
merci madame la Présidente avec votre
permission je défendrai également le 478
qui suit un peu plus loin madame la
ministre madame la rapporteur mes chers
collègues ces deux amendements visent à
confier aux missions locales
l'élaboration des orientations
stratégiques et l'animation en direction
des jeunes l'émission locale met en
oeuvre depuis 40 ans les politiques
publiques nationales et territoriales
d'insertion sociale et professionnelle
des jeunes ce sont sans aucun doute
l'émission les plus aptes à écouter les
besoins de nos jeunes et à évaluer les
conséquences des politiques publiques de
l'emploi la jeunesse c'est une période
compliquée parfois turbulente qui ne
répond pas toujours d'ailleurs à la
logique implacable des équations
mathématiques c'est pourquoi il est
important d'écouter les acteurs qui les
accompagnent et qui les comprennent
c'est à mon sens la seule condition pour
ne pas tomber dans un dialogue de sourds
qui desservirait les objectifs annoncés
de France travail aussi garantir aux
missions locales le copilotage des
politiques de l'emploi touchant les
jeunes c'est s'assurer de l'efficacité
et de l'acceptabilité de ces politiques
publiques merci de votre attention je
vous remercie nous passons maintenant 63
madame Guillotin il est défendu monsieur
Chassin 136
identique
madame la Présidente
identique mais je voudrais simplement
quand même indiquer que le réseau des
missions de France local souhaite
pouvoir aujourd'hui mettre son expertise
au service des membres du réseau France
travail pour contribuerait à répondre au
double des filles de l'amélioration de
la situation des jeunes dans tous les
domaines et la recherche du plein emploi
si Monsieur Genet merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre madame la
rapporteur cet article 4 vise à fédérer
des acteurs de l'emploi et de
l'insertion et renforcer leurs
coordination à tous les échelons du
territoire parmi ces acteurs il y a
naturellement l'émission locale et nos
collègues Antoine Lefebvre excellents
collègues Antoine Lefebvre mais
également notre collègue Dominique
Estrosi sason tout aussi excellente ont
déjà rappelé leur rôle leur singularité
leur efficacité mais moi qui vient d'un
territoire beaucoup moins beaucoup moins
chanceux que les leurs le Charolais
Brionnais je voudrais témoigner
effectivement et bien de ce qu'apporte
notre mission locale du Charolais
Brionnais par exemple en Saône-et-Loire
elle a au fil des années mis en place de
nombreux dispositifs pour apporter une
solution au problème rencontrées
certaines spécifiques au territoire
rural je pense en particulier à la
mobilité je pense à une auto-école
solidaire à une plateforme contre
l'illettrisme également à des solutions
matières de logement et donc madame la
ministre je pense que rassembler les
acteurs
ne doit pas se faire
au prix de l'efficacité de ce réseau
d'émission locale de leur capacité
d'autonomie qui est la garante de leur
capacité d'action et d'innovation et
donc c'est pourquoi nous proposons avec
cet amendement commun de pouvoir prévoir
que les missions locales assure une
fonction d'appui aux instances de
gouvernance mentionnés aux articles en
question pour les travaux concernant les
jeunes
merci madame la Présidente nous portons
également ce même amendement nous
l'avons nous avons déjà entendu je
dirais ce que nos collègues relais de
leur territoire des missions locales qui
nous ont interpellés par rapport à ce
projet de loi et donc nous aussi groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicains
nous pensons qu'il faut modifier quelque
peu ce texte de loin car dans le cadre
du rapport France travail il était prévu
que l'émission locale co-élaborent les
orientations stratégiques et quoi anime
les travaux de France travail concernant
les jeunes aux côtés de l'opérateur
France travail qui après son passage en
commission retrouve donc France travail
sa dénomination originale Pôle Emploi
forte de l'or 40 années d'expérience
émission locale véritable modèle de
décentralisation du service public ont
développé une expertise unique dans la
mise en oeuvre des politiques publiques
nationales et territoriales des
politiques d'insertion sociale et
professionnelle des jeunes elles ont
depuis leur création adop une méthode
originale l'approche globale de
l'accompagnement des jeunes que Pôle
Emploi promeut et en temps étendre à
d'autres publics la qualité de leurs
actions est aujourd'hui reconnue de tous
le gouvernement a d'ailleurs
considérablement conforté ces dernières
années leurs moyens bien que il soit
nécessaire aussi de
s'inscrire dans la durée et d'être dans
des engagements plus réannuels pour
aussi rassurer ses acteurs alors le
réseau des missions locales souhaitent
aujourd'hui pouvoir mettre son expertise
au service des membres du réseau France
travail pour contribuer à répondre au
double défis de l'amélioration de la
situation des jeunes dans tous les
domaines et de la recherche du plan
d'emploi je voudrais signaler mais vous
l'avez dit aussi que nous avons
travaillé nous avons échangé avec
l'Union nationale des missions locales
en dehors des missions locales
territoriales qui ont complété
l'argumentaire
merci madame la Présidente c'est
amendement de mon collègue Jean-Pierre
mougat étant très largement défendu je
le considère donc comme défendu madame
la rapporteur c'est à vous
merci madame la Présidente alors je
partage pleinement l'intention de ses
amendements l'émission locale ont
développé une expertise sur le terrain
pour l'insertion des jeunes et elle joue
un rôle clé pour les accompagner vers
l'emploi leur apporter soutien et être
face à leurs difficultés le réseau des
missions locales a su se développer
s'adapter aux différentes situations des
territoires des bassins d'emplois avec
le soutien des collectivités
territoriales et de l'État et on entend
bien entendu tous les exemples que vous
donnez de chacun de vos territoires pour
cette raison il est logique que
l'émission locale participent au Comité
national et
comment est toritorial France travaille
et qu'elle contribue à l'animation et au
pilotage de ces instances en assurant
une fonction d'appui elles pourront
importer leur expertise sur
l'accompagnement des jeunes et faire
remonter des informations des données
sur ce public auprès des membres du
Comité pour la définition des
orientations et des outils
considérons que Pôle Emploi sera aussi
cette fonction d'appui au titre de ces
compétences il me semble que
l'amendement numéro 2 de Madame canaillé
est préférable il prévoit bien cette
articulation des différentes fonctions
en donnant toutes leurs places aux
missions locales donc c'est un avis
favorable à la demande en numéro 2 de
Madame canaillé et c'est une demande de
retrait pour les autres amendements qui
poursuivent le même objectif la ministre
merci madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
l'article 5 du projet de loi et et
l'article 53 12-1 qui est créé dans
cette article 5 prévoit que les missions
communes au réseau France travail sont
mises en œuvre par l'opérateur France
travail en associant les autres
personnes morales constituant le réseau
France travail et donc notamment
l'émission locale le Gouvernement
partage votre volonté de conforter
l'esprit du texte en renforçant le rôle
de l'ensemble des acteurs du réseau dans
le cadre de la gouvernance et donc de
prévoir que l'ensemble des fonctions
communes y compris l'appui au Comité
National France travail au comité
territoriaux sont soit ainsi exercés en
partenariat c'est l'objet d'un
amendement qui est donc soutenu par le
gouvernement à l'article 5 l'objet est
donc le même que votre amendement mais
ça portait plus générale et sa rédaction
plus cohérente avec
l'économie du texte donc je vous propose
le retrait de ces amendements au profit
de l'amendement qui prévoit une
association des missions locales pour
l'exercice de l'ensemble des fonctions
communes je vous remercie alors je vais
d'abord mettre voix le l'amendement de
favorable la Commission et défavorable
du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté et tous les autres tombes nous
passons ensuite au 56
allez-y monsieur Kern merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre c'est
amendement vise à inclure les métropoles
dans les comités régionaux de formation
et d'orientation professionnelle et
ceux-ci dans un but d'assurer une
cohérence totale des interventions et il
nous semble donc approprié de les
inclure dans ces comités régionaux
merci
neuf qui madame monsieur Yann
défendu le 554 madame ponce
oui effectivement c'est
moi je m'inscrit tout à fait dans cet
amendement d'autant plus que
il est pas cette c'est une anomalie
quelque part du texte qui ne garantit à
aucun moment la présence des métropoles
dans les comités régionaux France
travail alors même que le texte il
prévoit une représentation des
départements de la région donc vraiment
cette proposition donc est tout à fait
cohérente et par ailleurs il est bon de
dire que le nombre réduit de métropoles
ne devrait pas modifier de façon
importante la taille de ces instances
donc c'est une c'est une question de
cohérence il apparaît légitime de
prévoir leur participation au comité
régionaux de l'orientation et de la
formation professionnelle pour les mêmes
raisons c'est l'objet de cet amendement
qui est travaillé en coopération avec
France urbaine
merci madame la Présidente ce sera un
avis défavorable sur l'ensemble de ses
amendements les créfopes sont composés
des représentants de la région et le
projet de loi ajoute déjà la présence
des représentants des départements alors
si on ajoute en plus des représentants
des métropoles il faudrait aussi prévoir
des représentants des communes et des
EPCI je rappelle en outre que le bloc
communal sera représenté dans les
comités locaux France travail donc c'est
un avis défavorable
ministre je mets aux voix d'abord les
deux amendements identiques double avis
défavoraptés pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient pas adopté
et le 554 qui est même vote même vote
ensuite nous prenons le 31 monsieur
blanc merci madame la Présidente il
n'est pas utile que la loi renvoie un
décret le soin de fixé la composition
ainsi que les missions et le
fonctionnement des commissions qui
peuvent être instituées au sein des
comités France travail je pense qu'il
faut laisser à chaque comité la liberté
de s'organiser il le fera comme il
l'entend
et cela est d'autant plus pertinent que
les commissions qui sont prévues et le
son à titre facultatif donc dans ces
conditions la ligne à 119 doit être
purement et simplement supprimé
monsieur de gueule pour le
le fendu en général madame Gatel
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre madame la rapporteur je pense
que l'excès de zèle tue quand en plus il
vient agir et définir par la loi dont on
dit qu'elle est trop souvent trop
bavarde l'organisation d'une commission
que la même loi définie comme
facultative je vous avoue que là c'est
un genre de d'Oscar de l'absurdité donc
il me semble que
l'amendement qui était bien défendu par
mes collègues que je partage mérite
l'attention de chacun je vous remercie
et enfin Madame ponce
oui effectivement cela renvoie donc il y
a un décret moi je pense que ça ça pose
aussi un principe démocratique qui
devrait parce que c'est un long contre
qui devrait d'un principe démocratique
qui devrait orienter le fonctionnement
d'organismes publics les plus importants
et ça risque également d'entacher
l'efficience des commissions qui sont la
participation de l'ensemble des
partenaires pertinents se prive de
ressources d'expertise de lien avec le
terrain et de savoir faire précieux par
ailleurs il semble qu'il convient plutôt
au comité territoriaux de choisir quelle
commission est créée et quels sont les
acteurs qui peuvent effectuer et figurer
mais qu'il soit essentiel à tous les
échelons qu'à certains nombre d'entre
eux soient présents quoi qu'il arrive
comme les syndicats personnels les
représentants des usagers les
collectivités les missions locales on en
a parlé Cap Emploi donc pour nous il
n'apparaît ni utile ni souhaitable que
la loi renvoie à un décret le soin de
fixer la composition de commission des
commissions c'est pourquoi cet
amendement travailler avec les régions
de France là aussi qu'on vient de le
dire se propose de supprimer cette
disposition dans la loi
quelle est la vie de la Commission sur
cette série d'amendements identiques
alors contrairement ce que dit l'objet
de l'amendement le décret visé ici doit
fixer la composition et les attributions
du créfort et non des comités
territoriaux France travail donc pour
nous il doit y avoir une erreur dans la
rédaction qui est proposée en fait dans
ses amendements cette disposition elle
est cohérente avec le fait que le comité
régional France travaille sera intégré
au greffe et qu'il faudra préciser sa
composition par voie réglementaire comme
pour les autres comités au niveau
national et territorial voilà donc c'est
un avis défavorable
je vais donc mettre voir cette série
d'abonnement identiques qui ont reçu un
double avis défavorable qui est pour
3 24
qui est contre
ils l'ont adopté
le 41
madame le werrou
oui c'est un amendement porté par notre
groupe et proposé par Madame jasmin
notre collègue il s'agit de supprimer
l'annulaire 80 en effet il y a une
logique de maintenir les compétences des
régions en matière de formation et
d'insertion puisqu'elles sont
compétentes en matière de développement
économique d'orientation et pour les
infrastructures des lycées l'influence
des collectivités régionales sur l'offre
d'emploi et sur les investissements
portés par les entreprises est
fondamentale et doit être conservée
notamment en outre-mer
merci quelle est la vie de la Commission
sur cet amendement
c'est un avis défavorable la présidente
l'amendement propose de maintenir des
dispositions dans le code du travail qui
sont relatives aux compétences de
coordination par la région du service
public de l'emploi et ces missions
dorénavant elles sont assurées par les
comités territoriaux France travail dans
lesquels les régions auront toutes leurs
places en particulier les comités
régionaux c'est donc par cohérence en
fait qu'on supprime les dispositions qui
sont visées et par coordination donc ces
modifications ne remettant aucun cas en
cause des compétences actuelles de la
région notamment en matière de formation
bien évidemment
mais ma vie je mets aux voix qui est
pour
qui pour qui est contre qui n'est pas
adopté sur le 610 je vais pas le mettre
je vais mettre aux enchères qui le prend
madame de scène